This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Imagine you're an architect, but instead of drawing up a plan for a skyscraper or a bridge, you've been asked to design the most sophisticated edifice in the universe. The human brain. Getting to work at your drafting table, you'd likely prioritize accuracy. You want this brain to perceive the world exactly as it is, a perfect mirror of reality. In your blueprint, the good and the bad, the rewarding and the threatening, all would be treated the same.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。想象一下，你是一名建筑师，但你不是在为摩天大楼或桥梁绘制蓝图，而是被要求设计宇宙中最复杂的建筑：人脑。当你坐在绘图桌前开始工作时，你可能会优先考虑准确性。你希望这个大脑能够如实地感知世界，成为现实的完美镜子。在你的蓝图中，好的和坏的、有回报的和具有威胁的，都将被同等对待。
Every event, every experience, would be assigned equal weight, given the same attention, and remembered equally. But as any architect will tell you, there is a vast gulf between a design that works on paper and one that actually survives the elements. The same is true of our own minds. The architect of evolution wasn't interested in making us objective observers or serene philosophers.
每一个事件，每一个经历，都会被赋予相等的权重，获得相同的关注，并被同等程度地记住。但正如任何建筑师都会告诉你那样，纸上谈兵的设计与真正能在现实环境中生存的设计之间，存在着巨大的鸿沟。我们自己的心灵也是如此。进化的建筑师并不在意把我们变成客观的观察者或平静的哲学家。
It wasn't trying to design a brain that took a fair and balanced view of the world. It was building a survival machine. To survive in a world filled with menacing predators, scarce resources, and social traps, the brain had to be designed with a series of built-in biases. Those are the same brains we have inside our heads today. It's why we focus more intently on some flavors of experience rather than others. In turn, these biases shape what? we perceive, how we respond, and even the course of our most intimate relationships.
它并非试图设计一个对世界持公平和平衡观点的大脑，而是在建造一台生存机器。为了在充满威胁的 predators（掠食者）、稀缺的资源和社交陷阱的世界中生存，大脑在设计时必须内置一系列偏差。这就是我们今天脑子里装着的大脑。这也是为什么我们会更专注地体验某些味道，而不是其他味道。反过来，这些偏差又会塑造我们的什么呢？我们如何感知，如何反应，甚至我们最亲密关系的发展轨迹。
This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, the lopsided ledgers in our minds, and how we can bring them into balance. Let's say you're a music critic attending a symphony. For two hours, 80 musicians play in perfect, breathtaking harmony. The strings are soaring, the brass is precise, and the conducting is fluid. But in the final minute of the performance, a single violinist hits a flat note. It lasts for less than a second, a tiny discordance in an otherwise flawless evening. When you sit down to write your review, what do you remember? If your brain were a perfect recording device, that one second error would be a mere blip,
本周的“隐藏大脑”以及“隐藏大脑 Plus”上的配套故事将探讨我们心灵中失衡的账本，以及我们如何才能让它们恢复平衡。假设你是一位参加交响音乐会的乐评人。在两个小时里，80位音乐家演奏出完美而令人叹为观止的和谐乐章。弦乐高亢激昂，铜管乐精确到位，指挥流畅自如。但在演出的最后一分钟，小提琴手弹出了一个不和谐的音符。它持续不到一秒钟，在一场原本无可挑剔的夜晚中显得极度不和谐。当你坐下来写乐评时，你记住的是什么？如果你的大脑是一个完美的录音设备，那么那一秒钟的失误只是一个小插曲，
buried under two hours of beauty. But for a critic, and that means all of us, that one flat note can become the entire. story. It lingers in our minds and shapes how we remember the evening. At the University of California Davis, psychologist Alison Ledgerwood studies how and why this happens. Alison Ledgerwood, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Alison, a few years ago, you noticed something peculiar about the way you responded to developments in your work life. What did you notice? I noticed that I could have a big success or a small success one day. An academic paper gets accepted or I meet a new work colleague who I'm really excited to become friends with. And that would be lovely. But then the next day or later that day, something negative would happen. A paper would get rejected. Somebody would snap at me in the hallway or not look happy to see me. And I couldn't get that negative out of my head.
被两小时的美妙音乐所掩埋。但对于乐评人来说——这意味着我们所有人——那一个不和谐的音符可能会变成整个故事。它挥之不去，并塑造了我们对当晚的记忆。在加州大学戴维斯分校，心理学家艾莉森·莱杰伍德研究这种现象是如何以及为什么发生的。艾莉森·莱杰伍德，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我来。艾莉森，几年前，你注意到自己对工作中进展的反应方式有些奇特。你注意到了什么？我注意到，某天我可能会取得一个重大或微小的成功。一篇学术论文被接受了，或者我结识了一位我很想和她成为朋友的新同事。那感觉会很好。但随后在第二天或当天晚些时候，负面的事情就会发生。一篇论文被拒绝了。有人在走廊里对我发脾气，或者看起来不想见到我。而我脑子里挥之不去全是这些负面的事情。
And this would happen even if the good thing was way more important than the bad thing when I took a step back. The negative seemed to stick with me all day, all week. You observed a similar dynamic when reading over your student evaluations. Some forms of feedback stick in your head. So I teach these big classes, 200 students, 300 students. And at the end of each quarter, you get teaching. evaluations that are passed out by the university and ask some questions about the class and the professor so that you can get feedback on what's going well and what you could do better. And often
即使当我退一步来看，好事明显比坏事重要得多，这种情况也依然会发生。负面的事情似乎一整天、一整周都缠着我。当你阅读学生给你的评价时，你也观察到了类似的情况。某些形式的反馈会一直留在你的脑海里。我教这些大班，有200名学生，300名学生。在每个学期结束时，你会收到大学分发的教学评估，上面有一些关于课程和教授的问题，这样你就可以获得关于哪些进展顺利以及你可以做哪些改进的反馈。通常情况下，
I would get a lot of glowing comments, right? I'm flipping through them and it's like, this is the best class I've taken so far at UC Davis and this was one of the best professors I've ever had and everything seems rosy. And then I would come across a single negative comment, right? So, somebody says, I could have found all of this online. And I'm devastated. I'm counter-arguing in my head. I'm thinking about the hours and hours and hours of work I put into pulling together these sources from different places so that the students wouldn't have to just have everything canned from a textbook. And then I start thinking they don't appreciate this, as if it's the whole class. None of them want to be in this class.
我会收到很多热情洋溢的评论，对吧？我翻看着它们，心想：这是我在加州大学戴维斯分校上过最好的课，这是我遇到过最好的教授之一，一切看起来都一帆风顺。然后我会偶然看到一条负面的评论，对吧？有人说：这些内容我完全可以在网上找到。我崩溃了。我在脑子里进行反驳。我想到了自己为了把这些来自不同地方的资料整合在一起，投入了成百上千个小时的工作，这样学生们就不必仅仅接受教科书里的那些死板内容。然后我开始想，他们并不感激这一点，就好像全班都这样。他们根本不想上这门课。
They would just rather be finding this information on YouTube. Why am I even here? Instead of contextualizing that as one comment out of the hundreds that I had gotten, right? Now, I think many people have experienced what you've experienced, Allison. And of course, it doesn't just happen in work settings. You were driving recently when you noticed the same thing at work. Exactly. So a few weeks ago, I had this perfectly lovely day, and I was driving to pick up my kid from school.
他们宁愿去 YouTube 上找这些信息。我为什么还要在这里？而不是把它看作是我收到的数百条评论中的一条普通评论，对吧？现在，我想很多人都经历过你所经历的事情，艾莉森。当然，这不仅仅发生在工作环境中。你最近在开车时，也注意到了职场中同样的情况。完全正确。所以就在几周前，我度过了完美美好的一天，当时我正开车去接孩子放学。
And I slowed down and stopped for somebody who was jaywalking across the street. And instead of saying, thank you, or even just ignoring me, she yelled at me. I think because it actually took her longer to wait and figure out if I was going or not than to just cross the street. But for whatever reason, she yells at me. And it takes me like an hour to stop feeling bad about it and perseverating on it. and wondering, should I have done something different? What did I do wrong? Let's talk a moment about how this tendency to focus on the negative
我减速并停下来，让一个在街上乱穿马路的行人先过。她没有说谢谢，甚至没有忽视我，反而对我大喊大叫。我想这其实是因为她花在等待并弄清楚我是不是要开过去的时间，比直接过马路还要长。但不管出于什么原因，她对我大吼大叫。我花了大约一个小时才不再为此感到难过，不再对此耿耿于怀，不再去想：我是不是应该做点别的？我到底做错了什么？让我们花一点时间来讨论一下这种专注于负面的倾向，
shows up not just in our personal lives, but also in the way we respond to the news. Between 2001 and 2004, NASA directed the voyage of a space probe called Genesis. It was a truly extraordinary piece of engineering designed to capture particles ejected from the sun for the very first time, truly an incredible. incredible feat of science. What happened on this voyage, Alison, and how do we remember it? You know, you could argue that the Genesis space mission was 99% an amazing success. This was
不仅体现在我们的个人生活中，也体现在我们对新闻的反应方式上。在2001年至2004年期间，美国宇航局（NASA）领导了一次名为“创世纪号”的空间探测器任务。这是一项真正非凡的工程壮举，旨在首次捕获从太阳喷射出的粒子，这确实是一项不可思议的科学成就。艾莉森，这次任务发生了什么，我们又是如何记住它的？你知道，你可以说“创世纪号”太空任务99%取得了惊人的成功。这是
the first NASA space probe to go out and collect material beyond the moon's orbit and bring it back to Earth. The mission had three major scientific objectives, and all of them were met. But that's not what the headlines reported at the time, or what many people remember about Genesis because at the very end, after all of the successes, because of a tiny mistake in how some sensors were installed, the probe crash landed in the Utah desert. And that made the whole thing feel like a failure. It looks like we have a no shoot, sir. Pector 210. patient managers, FECC, negative throat, negative shoot. Impact at 5-8-5-5 past air. Now, the probe had traveled something like a billion miles. That's billion with a B.
美国宇航局第一个走出并收集月球轨道以外物质并将其带回地球的空间探测器。该任务有三个主要的科学目标，并且全部都得到了实现。但当时的新闻头条并没有这样报道，许多人对“创世纪号”的记忆也不是这样的，因为在最后，在经历了所有的成功之后，由于安装某些传感器时的一个微小失误，探测器在犹他州沙漠坠毁了。这让整件事感觉像是一场失败。看起来我们没有开伞，先生。Pector 210。病人经理，FECC，负面咽喉，负面开伞。在空气消散5-8-5-5时撞击。现在，探测器已经飞行了大约十亿英里。这是带B的十亿。
And in fact, much of the scientific information that the probe was sent to collect was, in fact, collected. And from a scientific point of view, the mission was a success, but that's not how we remember it. Exactly. We focused on that one little thing that went wrong. I mean, crashing is not tiny. crashing is a big crash. But in terms of exactly, as you said, the scientific objectives of the mission,
事实上，探测器被派遣去收集的大部分科学信息，确实都被收集到了。从科学的角度来看，这次任务是成功的，但我们并不是这样记住它的。没错。我们将注意力集中在那件出错的小事上。我的意思是，坠毁可不是小事。坠毁是一场大事故。但正如你所说，就任务的科学目标而言，
it was a small blip. The scientists were able to recover the information they needed, and yet we think of it as a failure. Let's talk a moment about how our tendency to harp on the negative can shape even geopolitical conflict and war. Some years ago, Alison,
这只是一个小插曲。科学家们成功恢复了他们需要的信息，然而我们却认为这是一次失败。让我们花点时间来谈谈，我们对负面因素的执念是如何塑造地缘政治冲突和战争的。几年前，艾莉森，
researchers produced an in-depth analysis of how Germany ended up in World War I, not because necessarily it was under threat, but because it believed that it was under threat from its neighbors. Right. So if you're a country and you are looking for possible problems,
研究人员对德国是如何陷入第一次世界大战进行了深入分析，这并非一定是因为它受到了威胁，而是因为它坚信自己受到了邻国的威胁。没错。所以如果你是一个国家，并且你在寻找可能的问题、
possible threats to address, it makes sense, right, that the possibility of a threat would grab your attention and it could lead you to make some bad choices because you kind of overestimate the strength of that threat. I mean, this was probably true even when it came to something like the Cold War,
需要解决的潜在威胁，那么威胁的可能性会吸引你的注意力，这是合情合理的，而这可能会导致你做出一些糟糕的选择，因为你有点高估了这种威胁的强度。我的意思是，即使在冷战时期，这种情况大概也是真实的，
the United States and the Soviet Union greatly overestimated how belligerent and dangerous the other side was and effectively brought the whole world to the brink of annihilation. Right. Each side is focusing on what could go wrong. They're focusing on the possibility of that threat and focusing so much on the possibility of something going wrong without also focusing on the possibility that it could go right, right, that things could. de-escalate, leads to this kind of escalating, oh, no, we better be prepared for the worst possible case. And then, oh, no, we'd better be prepared for the worst possible case and on and on. And it's so interesting, I think, when we think about geopolitical conflict or the ways that nations interact with each other, I think we often forget that there are human beings who are basically involved in these negotiations. These are human beings who are making judgments. And so in some ways, it ought to be unsurprising that the way our minds think should shape these major, major events.
美国和苏联大大高估了对方的好战性和危险性，并实际上把整个世界推到了毁灭的边缘。没错。双方都把焦点放在可能出错的事情上。他们专注于这种威胁的可能性，过度关注可能出错的事情，却忽视了事情可能变好的可能性，即局势可能会缓和，从而导致这种不断升级的循环，哦，天哪，我们最好为最坏的情况做好准备。然后又变成，哦，天哪，我们最好为最坏的情况做好准备，如此循环往复。我认为，每当我们思考地缘政治冲突或国家之间的互动方式时，最有趣的是，我们经常忘记，基本上涉及这些谈判的是人类。是人类在做出判断。所以在某种程度上，我们的思维方式塑造了这些重大事件，这应该并不令人意外。
I couldn't agree more. And I think you see this in all kinds of settings, right? We think of historical forces as somehow not being biased by human psychology. And in all of these cases, right, we're squishy humans, we're fallible. We have all kinds of biases in our minds that influence how we think and how we make sometimes very consequential. decisions. The human brain operates like a very curious kind of magnet. It remains indifferent to shavings of silver and gold,
我完全赞同。我认为你在各种环境中都能看到这一点，对吧？我们认为历史力量在某种程度上没有受到人类心理的偏见影响。但在所有这些情况下，对吧，我们都是脆弱的人类，我们都会犯错。我们心中有各种各样的偏见，影响着我们的思考方式，以及我们有时会做出的具有重大影响的决策。人脑的运作方式就像一块非常奇特的磁铁。它对银屑和金屑无动于衷，
but it's drawn to heavy, jagged shards of lead and iron. When we come back, why our minds are irresistibly drawn to the negative? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 1777, the English writer Samuel John, was talking with his friend and biographer James Boswell about the case of an Anglican clergyman who had been sentenced to death for forgery. Samuel Johnson remarked to his companion, Depend on it, sir, when a man knows he is to be hanged in a fortnight, it concentrates his mind wonderfully.
却被沉重、参差不齐的铅和铁碎片所吸引。稍后回来，为什么我们的大脑不可抗拒地被负面事物所吸引？你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。1777年，英国作家塞缪尔·约翰逊与他的朋友兼传记作家詹姆斯·博斯韦尔谈论了一名因伪造罪被判处死刑的圣公会牧师的案件。塞缪尔·约翰逊对他的同伴说：“相信我，先生，当一个人知道自己将在两周内被绞死时，这会使他的思想高度集中。”
Even when the fate we are facing is far less severe than an execution, bad news tends to concentrate the mind. It crowds out the happy aspects of our existence. At the University of California Davis, psychologist Allison Ledgerwood studies why this happens in the brain. Allison, we've been talking about the effects of what psychologists call the negativity bias. What is this bias? Simply put, the negativity bias is the tendency for our brains to look for negative information and then hold onto it once we find it. This shows up in a lot of different ways, and the version that I study is that once we can, think about something in negative terms, that way of thinking about it tends to stick in our minds
即使我们面临的命运远没有处决那么严酷，坏消息也往往会使人的思想集中。它会排挤掉我们存在中的快乐面。在加州大学戴维斯分校，心理学家艾莉森·莱杰伍德研究大脑中为什么会发生这种情况。艾莉森，我们一直在讨论心理学家所说的“ negativity bias（负面偏误）”的影响。什么是这种偏误？简而言之，负面偏误是指我们的大脑寻找负面信息，一旦找到就紧抓不放的倾向。这在很多不同的方面都有所体现，而我研究的版本是，一旦我们能够用负面的词汇来思考某件事，这种思考方式往往就会留在我们的脑海中，
and resist subsequent attempts to change it. Why would our brains be designed this way, Alison? You know, we can tell an evolutionary story. I like to remind myself that we can't go back in time and like experimentally test that this is what happened. But it makes sense from an evolutionary perspective to think that, you know, when you're wandering along the plane in our ancestral past and you encounter a tiger, you really want a brain in that moment that's going to say, oh, hey, there's a tiger, and that's not going to forget about the tiger because you happen to glance at a tree and it looks pretty in the afternoon light, right? You want a brain that's going to say, tiger, tiger, and not stop saying tiger for a while after that.
并且会抗拒随后的改变尝试。艾莉森，为什么我们的大脑会被设计成这样？你知道，我们可以讲述一个进化的故事。我喜欢提醒自己，我们无法回到过去并通过实验来测试这就是发生的事情。但从进化的角度来看，这是合乎逻辑的：当你漫步在我们祖先过去的平原上并遇到一只老虎时，在那一刻，你真的很希望大脑会说：“哦，嘿，那里有一只老虎”，并且不会因为你恰好瞥了一眼一棵在午后阳光下看起来很漂亮的树而忘记这只老虎，对吧？你希望大脑会说：“老虎，老虎”，并且在此之后的一段时间里不要停止说“老虎”。
So in some ways, the idea is that in our evolutionary past, at least, there was survival value in being very focused on negative or threatening information. Exactly. You want your mind to focus on potential threats. You also want your mind to focus on mistakes. When we make a mistake, our mind fixates on it. Our body might feel bad, right? Guilty or upset or disappointed. And that's our brain and our body saying, hey, that didn't go the way that we wanted it to go. Next time, maybe we could do something different. But of course, now that translates into a professor teaching her students, getting 199 positive reviews, and then getting one negative review and saying, oh, my God, let me focus
所以在某种程度上，这个想法是，至少在我们的进化过去中，高度关注负面或威胁性信息具有生存价值。没错。你希望你的大脑专注于潜在的威胁。你还希望大脑专注于错误。当我们犯错时，我们的大脑会对此执着。我们的身体可能会感觉不好，对吧？感到内疚、沮丧或失望。这是我们的大脑和身体在说：“嘿，事情没有按照我们希望的方向发展。”下次，也许我们可以做点别的事。但当然，现在这转化为一个教授给学生上课，收到了199条正面评价，然后收到一条负面评价，然后说：“哦，天哪，让我关注
on the negative review, the negative review, the negative review. Absolutely. So sometimes the negativity bias in our minds is really functional. It helps us learn from mistakes. It helps us identify problems that we need to fix, often in collaboration with other people. And sometimes it just gets you stuck on something that doesn't seem to have any use that you would rather not be thinking about. Now, the brain's tendency to react more strongly to negative information has been demonstrated even in brain imaging studies. What do these show us, Alison? Some of my favorite work on this comes from Tiffany Edo, a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Colorado, Boulder. And in some of her work, she showed participants a series of pictures that were positive or negative or neutral.
负面评价吧，负面评价，负面评价。”绝对是这样。所以有时我们大脑中的负面偏误是非常实用的。它帮助我们从错误中吸取教训。它帮助我们识别需要解决的问题，通常是通过与其他人的合作。有时它只是让你陷入某种似乎毫无用处、你宁愿不去想的事情中。现在，大脑对负面信息反应更强烈的倾向，甚至已经在脑成像研究中得到了证实。艾莉森，这些向我们展示了什么？我最喜欢的一些关于这方面的研究来自科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的心理学家和神经科学家蒂凡尼·埃多。在她的一些研究中，她向参与者展示了一系列正面、负面或中性的图片。
And she measured event-related brain potentials or ERPs, which basically just capture how the brain is responding to a stimulus. She found that participants' brains responded more strongly to negative images than to positive images, suggesting that the negative motivational system responds more intensely than the positive motivational system. Now, I suppose we can notice our tendency to overweight the negative, and we might wish that our brains didn't do this. But if we could wave a magic wand and make this happen, if we could remove our tendency to focus on the negative, would that be a good thing, Alison? I don't think so at all, Shankar. And the reason is because of this function of negativity bias that we talked about earlier, it is useful to pay attention to real threats. It is useful to pay attention to real mistakes that we can learn and grow from and do better next time.
她测量了事件相关电位（ERP），这基本上捕捉了大脑对刺激的反应方式。她发现，参与者的大脑对负面图片的反应比对正面图片的反应更强烈，这表明负面动机系统的反应比正面动机系统更强烈。现在，我想我们可以注意到我们过度重视负面因素的倾向，并且我们可能希望大脑不要这样做。但如果我们能挥动魔杖让这成为现实，如果我们能消除专注于负面的倾向，这会是一件好事吗，艾莉森？尚卡尔，我一点也不这么认为。原因正是我们前面讨论过的负面偏误的功能：关注真正的威胁是有用的。关注真正的错误是有用的，我们可以从中吸取教训、成长并在下次做得更好。
And it is useful to pay attention to real problems in our environment, in society, in the situation around us that we can address by working together with other people. So in some ways, it's a dilemma because we have what is arguably a very useful feature of our minds. But that useful feature also produces a lot of unhappiness because we are so, you know, so focused on the negative rather than the positive. Exactly. You've been particularly interested in the idea of framing. Things in the world aren't necessarily inherently positive or negative. We can feel differently about the same person or object or event,
关注我们环境中、社会中、周围局势中可以通过与他人合作来解决的真正问题，也是有用的。所以在某种程度上，这是一个两难境地，因为我们拥有可以说是大脑中非常有用的一种功能。但这种有用的功能也带来了很多不快乐，因为我们太过于……专注于负面，而不是正面。完全正确。你一直对“框架效应”的概念特别感兴趣。世界上的事情不一定本身就是正面或负面的。对于同一个人、物体或事件，我们的感受可能会有所不同，
depending on how it's described. Why is framing so significant, Allison? There's tons of research across many different disciplines, political science, psychology, economics, focused on this. idea of framing, that the way that we feel about a person or an event is going to change depending on how it's described or framed. And at its heart, at the most basic level, this is just that proverbial glass that can be seen as half full or half empty. It matters how somebody describes the glass to you. If somebody says, hey, look at this half full glass, you think,
这取决于它是如何被描述的。艾莉森，为什么框架效应如此重要？跨越许多不同学科（政治学、心理学、经济学）有大量研究都聚焦于这个框架的概念，即我们对一个人或事件的感受会随着对其描述或框架的不同而改变。在其核心，在最基础的层面上，这就像那句老话：杯子可以看作是半满的，也可以看作是半空的。别人如何向你描述这个杯子很重要。如果有人说：“嘿，看看这个半满的杯子”，你会想，
this is great. There's water in there. If somebody says, hey, look at this half empty. glass, you think, oh no, it's half empty. The psychologist Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky once conducted an influential study on the effects of framing. Can you describe the study for me and what it found? Conneman and Tversky conducted early work showing that seemingly trivial changes in wording could produce really striking changes in people's preferences. So in their 1981 research, they told participants, imagine that there's been an outbreak of an unusual disease and 600 lives are at stake. And then they randomly assigned people in their study to one of
这太棒了。里面有水。如果有人说：“嘿，看这个半空的杯子”，你会想，哦不，它是半空的。心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基曾就框架效应的影响进行过一项具有影响力的研究。你能为我描述一下这项研究及其发现吗？卡尼曼和特沃斯基早期的研究表明，措辞看似微不足道的改变可能会导致人们偏好发生惊人的变化。因此，在他们1981年的研究中，他们告诉参与者：想象一下爆发了一种不寻常的疾病，有600人的生命受到威胁。然后他们将研究中的参与者随机分配到
two groups. For the first group, they went on to describe some possible response options in terms of how many lives would be saved. If you go in this direction, this many lives would be saved. If you go with this response instead, that many lives will be saved. For the second group, they described those same options in terms of how many lives would be lost. So, for example, out of 600 lives, you're thinking in one case about the 400 that will be saved or in the other case, the 200 that will be lost. What Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky found was that simply framing outcomes in positive or negative terms dramatically altered people's preferences. When choices were framed in terms of lives saved, people tended to avoid risk. When those same choices were framed in terms of lives lost,
两组中的一组。对于第一组，他们继续用“将拯救多少生命”来描述一些可能的应对方案。如果你朝着这个方向走，这么多生命将得救。如果你选择这个应对方案，那么多生命将得救。对于第二组，他们用“将损失多少生命”来描述相同的选项。因此，例如，在600条生命中，在一种情况下，你想到的是将被拯救的400人，或者在另一种情况下，想到的是将失去的200人。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基发现，仅仅用正面或负面的术语来构建结果，就会极大地改变人们的偏好。当选择以拯救的生命来构建时，人们倾向于规避风险。当这些相同的选择以失去的生命来构建时，
people became more willing to gamble. I asked Allison to tell me about other words, work that also looks at how we describe the successes or failures of groups and how we then come to see those groups. So in one of these studies, professionals were asked to evaluate a work team based on some information about that team's past performance. Half of the participants in the study randomly assigned were told that 30 out of 50 of the team's past projects had been successful. The other half of the participants were told that 20 out of 50 of the team's past projects had been unsuccessful. So mathematically, it's the same identical information, right? But some participants were focused on the part of the glass that was full. Some participants were focused on
人们变得更愿意去赌一把。我请艾莉森告诉我关于其他人的研究工作，这些研究也探讨了我们如何描述团队的成功或失败，以及我们随后如何看待这些团队。因此，在其中一项研究中，专业人员被要求根据关于某个团队过去绩效的一些信息来评估该团队。研究中一半被随机分配的参与者被告知，该团队过去的50个项目中，有30个是成功的。另一半参与者被告知，该团队过去的50个项目中，有20个是不成功的。所以从数学上讲，这是完全相同的信息，对吧？但一些参与者专注于杯子满的那部分。一些参与者专注于
the part of the glass that was empty. And then the question was, do you fund the work team? Like, how likely are they to succeed? And participants wanted to fund the team more when its past performance had been described in terms of successes than when its past performance had been described in terms of failure. I understand the same phenomenon is sometimes at work in medical settings when patients are deciding whether to go forward with a surgery. How the surgery is described can change whether we decide it's a good idea or a bad idea. Right. So imagine I tell you, a national panel is evaluating a recently developed surgical procedure that involves new robotic technology. And a three-year study on the procedure just concluded, based on the data, experts agree that it has a survival rate of 70 percent.
杯子空的那部分。然后问题是，你是否资助这个工作团队？比如，他们成功的可能性有多大？当过去绩效被描述为成功时，参与者比过去绩效被描述为失败时，更愿意资助该团队。我了解到，在医疗环境中，当患者决定是否进行手术时，有时也会发生同样的现象。手术的描述方式可以改变我们决定这是个好主意还是个坏主意。没错。所以想象一下我告诉你：一个国家小组正在评估最近开发的一项涉及新机器人技术的外科手术。关于该手术为期三年的研究刚刚结束，根据数据，专家一致认为其生存率为70%。
Or, I tell you, it has a mortality rate of 30 percent. Same information again. But participants in a study like this are much more favorable towards the procedure when it's described in terms of the survival rate than when it's described in terms of the mortality rate. Now, on its surface, these framing effects might not seem like they're about the negativity by. or at least they are not about the negativity bias alone. When you tell people the surgical procedure has a 70% survival rate, people do focus on that positive news. But here is how the negativity bias kicks in.
或者，我告诉你：它的死亡率为30%。依然是相同的信息。但参与这项研究的参与者，当手术被描述为生存率时，对其的好感度要远高于将其描述为死亡率时。现在，表面上看，这些框架效应似乎与负面偏误无关，或者至少它们不仅仅与负面偏误有关。当你告诉人们外科手术有70%的生存率时，人们确实会关注那个好消息。但负面偏误在这里开始发挥作用了。
Allison has run studies where people are presented either the positive or the negative information. Then she presents people with the other side of the coin. The people who got the positive framing first now get the negative framing. The people who got the negative framing. The people who got the negative. framing about the mortality rate of the procedure are now presented the same information with
艾莉森进行过这样的研究：向人们展示正面或负面的信息。然后她向人们展示硬币的另一面。首先获得正面框架的人现在获得了负面框架。获得关于手术死亡率的负面框架的人，现在被呈现了相同的信息，但换成了
the positive framing, the survival rate. In our research, we start out the same way that all these framing studies have in the past. Half the participants see a person, a politician, an event, a surgical procedure framed in positive terms. Half of them see that same thing framed in negative terms. But unlike in past research, we don't stop there. we keep going. So people in our studies who see, let's say, a surgical procedure framed in terms of its survival rate at time one, then see it reframed in terms of its mortality rate at time two.
正面框架，即生存率。在我们的研究中，我们一开始的做法与过去所有这些框架研究都一样。一半的参与者看到一个人、一个政治家、一个事件、一个外科手术被框定在正面的词汇中。一半人看到同样的事物被框定在负面的词汇中。但与过去的研究不同，我们没有就此停步，我们继续进行下去。因此，在我们研究中看到诸如某个外科手术在时间一时被框定为生存率的人，随后在时间二看到它被重新框定为死亡率。
People who originally see the surgical procedure framed in terms of its mortality rate, then later see it reframed in terms of its survival rate. And our question is, can people just follow along with this as the vast literature on framing seemed to suggest, right? People just react to the frame that's right in front of them. I like the half full glass. I dislike the half empty glass, so maybe I can bounce back and forth easily between them. But that's not what we found, or it's only what we find half the time. When people see a positive frame first and then it switches to a negative frame, survival rate switches to mortality rate, they follow right along. They like the procedure at first.
最初看到外科手术被框定为死亡率的人，后来又看到了它被重新框定为生存率。我们的问题是：人们能顺着这个思路走下去吗，正如关于框架的大量研究所暗示的那样，对吧？人们只是对眼前的框架做出反应。我喜欢半满的杯子，我讨厌半空的杯子，所以也许我可以轻松地在它们之间来回弹跳。但这并不是我们发现的结果，或者这只是我们有一半时间能发现的结果。当人们首先看到一个正面框架，然后它切换到负面框架（生存率切换到死亡率）时，他们会顺着走下去。他们一开始喜欢这个手术。
When you reframe it, they don't like it anymore. But when we move in the opposite direction, when we start out with negatives and reframe as positives, participants tend to get stuck in the initial negative framing. They don't like the procedure when it's described in terms of mortality. And then when we say, hey, you can think of this in terms of survival rate, they still don't like it. So in other words, if you tell me the procedure has a 70% survival rate and I like it, but then you tell me it has a 30% mortality rate, I changed my mind and I now stop liking it.
当你重新构架它时，他们就不再喜欢了。但当我们朝着相反的方向移动时，当我们从负面开始并将其重新构建为正面时，参与者往往会陷入最初的负面框架中。当手术被描述为死亡率时，他们不喜欢它。然后当我们说，嘿，你可以从生存率的角度来考虑这一点时，他们依然不喜欢它。换句话说，如果你告诉我这个手术有70%的生存率并且我喜欢它，但随后你告诉我它有30%的死亡率，我改变了主意，现在不再喜欢它了。
But if you start out telling me it has a 30% mortality rate, I don't like it, and now if you tell me it has a 70% survival rate, I still don't like it. Yes, that initial negative frame seems to stick in your head and resist subsequent attempts to change it. What does this tell you that in some ways things seem to drift almost toward the negative side of the equation? I think that our brains have a tent. tendency to tilt towards the negative, right? That just fundamental negativity bias that our minds
但如果你一开始告诉我它有30%的死亡率，我不喜欢它，而现在如果你告诉我它有70%的生存率，我依然不喜欢它。是的，最初的负面框架似乎会留在你的脑海中，并抗拒随后的改变尝试。这说明了什么：在某种程度上，事物似乎几乎会向方程式的负面倾斜？我认为我们的大脑有一种倾向，即倾向于负面，对吧？也就是我们的大脑会寻找负面信息，
look for negative information and then hold on to it once we find it. And I think this is one way that our brains do that, that our brains are holding on to the initial conceptualization of something as negative. And it's really hard to switch things around and start thinking of it as positive. When you see these framing effects and you see that we tend to go from a a positive frame to a negative frame fairly easily, but not so easily from a negative frame to a positive frame. Do you have any understanding of how this is actually happening in the brain, Alison? Yeah, so this was a question that we were really curious about, and we've looked at it in a few different ways. But probably my favorite is that we gave people a very simple math problem. We
一旦找到就紧抓不放的这种基本负面偏误。我认为这是我们大脑做到这一点的一种方式，我们的大脑抓住了对某事物的最初负面概念化。而且要扭转局面并开始将其视为正面是非常困难的。当你看到这些框架效应，并且发现我们往往可以相当容易地从正面框架过渡到负面框架，但从负面框架过渡到正面框架却没那么容易时，艾莉森，你对这在脑海中是如何实际发生的有什么理解吗？是的，所以这是我们很好奇的一个问题，我们从几个不同的角度研究了它。但可能我最喜欢的是，我们给人们出了一个非常简单的数学题。我们
told them, imagine there's been an outbreak of an unusual disease and 600 lives are at stake, so that classic connemann and Tversky framing study. And then we just asked them if 100 lives are saved, how many will be lost? Or if 100 lives are lost, how many will be saved? So everyone just has to calculate 600 minus 100 and come up with the answer of 500. But whereas some people have to convert from positives to negatives to get that answer, the second group, the other people have to convert from negatives to positives. Can you unpack that last part just a little bit more?
告诉他们：想象一下爆发了一种不寻常的疾病，有600人的生命受到威胁，也就是卡尼曼和特沃斯基的经典框架研究。然后我们只是问他们，如果拯救了100条生命，将失去多少生命？或者如果失去了100条生命，将拯救多少生命？所以每个人只需要计算600减去100，得出500的答案。但鉴于有些人必须从正面转换到负面才能得到这个答案，第二组（其他人）则必须从负面转换到正面。你能再稍微解释一下最后一部分吗？
Sure. So some people to solve the problem of 600 minus 100 have to convert from lives saved to lives lost, right? If 100 lives are saved, how many will be lost? Other people are doing the same math problem, but they're calculating if 100 lives are lost, how many will be saved. and then we timed how long it took them to solve the problem. Everyone can do it in a few seconds, but it takes people significantly longer
当然。因此，为了解决600减100的问题，有些人必须从“被拯救的生命”转换到“失去的生命”，对吧？如果拯救了100条生命，将失去多少生命？其他人则在做同样的数学题，但他们在计算如果失去了100条生命，将拯救多少生命。然后我们记录了他们解决这个问题花了多长时间。每个人都可以在几秒钟内完成，但当数学题涉及从负面转换到正面时，人们花费的时间要明显长得多，
when the math problem involves converting from negatives to positives than when it involves converting from positives to negatives. So it's almost as if you have a, you know, if the brain was a freeway system or a road system, the negativity information flows on the highways and the positivity information flows on the back streets. I love that analogy, yeah. Our minds tend to focus on things that are threatening or distressing.
而不是涉及从正面转换到负面时。所以这就好像你有一个，你知道的，如果大脑是一个高速公路系统或道路系统，负面信息在高速公路上流动，而正面信息在后街小巷流动。我喜欢这个比喻，是的。我们的大脑倾向于关注那些具有威胁性或令人痛苦的事情。
Often, what this means is that we walk around with an excessively negative view of our lives and the world. But there are ways to manage our tendency to focus on the negative and even ways to turn this bias to our advantage. When we come back, rebalancing bad with good. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain.
通常，这意味着我们带着对生活和世界的过度负面看法四处走动。但有一些方法可以管理我们关注负面的倾向，甚至有方法将这种偏误转变为我们的优势。稍后回来，重新平衡坏事与好事。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Can you think of a time in your life when something negative crowded out all the positive things? Did this have consequences for the way you behaved and the opportunities you were able to see? If you have a personal story
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你能想起你生命中有什么负面事情排挤了所有正面事情的时刻吗？这是否对你的行为方式以及你所能看到的机遇产生了影响？如果你有一个个人故事
you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback. at HiddenBrain.org using the subject line, negative. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org.
愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件发送给我们，邮箱是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org，主题行使用：negative。再次强调，邮箱是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。
Alison Ledgerwood is a psychologist at the University of California, Davis. She studies the tendency of the brain to focus on the negative and how different frames can change the way we see events in a positive light or a negative light. Now, Alison, as we've discussed, the goal here is not to eliminate our tendency to focus on the negative. They can be real value and benefit in noticing things that are dangerous or threatening or wrong. However, it is the case that the bias that we have toward the negative causes many of us to walk around feeling like our lives are much worse than they actually are. You say one way to combat this problem is to make an effort to notice things about our lives that are positive? You know, what I take away from this research for my own life in part is that our brains have this fundamental tendency to tilt.
艾莉森·莱杰伍德是加州大学戴维斯分校的心理学家。她研究大脑关注负面的倾向，以及不同的框架如何改变我们以正面或负面眼光看待事件的方式。现在，艾莉森，正如我们所讨论的，这里的目标不是消除我们关注负面的倾向。注意到危险、具威胁性或错误的事物可能具有真实的价值和益处。然而，事实是，我们对负面的偏误导致我们许多人走来走去，感觉生活比实际情况要糟糕得多。你说克服这个问题的其中一个方法是努力注意到我们生活中积极的事情？你知道，从这项研究中，我对我自己的生活得出的一部分体会是，我们的大脑对负面有着这种基本的倾斜倾向。
toward the negative. But exactly as you say, it doesn't work to suppress negativity. In fact, there's plenty of research showing that when you try to suppress negative emotions, it makes the negativity rebound stronger than ever. So we have to acknowledge the negatives. And as you pointed out, we can often use that to our advantage to work to change problems in our environment. But we can also try to help even out our brains, try to make it a little bit easier for our brains to also notice the positives. And we can just do that through practice, the same way that we learn any kind of cognitive or behavioral habit, right? Think about the first time you're driving in a new route to work. You have to pay a lot of attention. It's kind of hard. Maybe you make a wrong turn.
但正如你所说，压制负面情绪是行不通的。事实上，有大量研究表明，当你试图压制负面情绪时，它会使负面情绪的反弹比以往任何时候都强烈。所以我们必须承认负面情绪。正如你所指出的，我们经常可以利用这一点来为我们所用，以解决我们环境中的问题。但我们也可以尝试帮助我们的心灵趋于平衡，试着让大脑更容易地注意到正面。我们可以通过练习做到这一点，就像我们学习任何认知或行为习惯一样，对吧？想想你第一次开车走一条去上班的新路线。你必须高度集中注意力。这有点难。也许你走错了路。
But the 73rd time you are driving or walking or biking, that same route, you can just do it automatically. It's easy. So the same thing happens with a new way of thinking as a new way of behaving. We can practice thinking of positives and use that to not counteract or replace, but to complement our brain's strength of focusing on negatives. I understand that your colleague Robert Emmons has found that we can spend just a couple of minutes every day, and that can help us retrieve the positive things in our lives?
但当你第73次开车、走路或骑自行车走同一条路线时，你就可以自动完成了。这很简单。同样的道理也适用于一种新的思维方式作为一种新的行为方式。我们可以练习思考正面情绪，并用它来补充（而不是对抗或替代）大脑关注负面的优势。我了解到，你的同事罗伯特·埃蒙斯发现，我们每天只需花几分钟时间，这就可以帮助我们找回生活中的积极事物？
Yeah, so in his research, he had participants write for just a few minutes a day about things that they felt grateful or thankful for and found that it substantially boosted their well-being over the course of the study. There's other research by my colleague, Tomika Unida, showing that sharing positives with other people can have a real boost for your health. So she looked at older couples sharing positive emotions during their day or having those positive emotions on their own. And she found that when they shared the positive emotions, that was uniquely good for health. It lowered their cortisol and actually had a lasting effect throughout the day. Talk about why this might happen, Alison. Why is it important for us to express
是的，所以在他的研究中，他让参与者每天花几分钟时间写下他们感激或感谢的事情，并发现这在整个研究过程中显著提升了他们的幸福感。我的同事尤美卡·乌尼达还有其他研究表明，与其他人分享积极事物可以极大地提升你的健康。因此，她观察了老年夫妇在日常生活中分享积极情绪，或者自己拥有这些积极情绪。她发现，当他们分享积极情绪时，对健康有着独特的好处。它降低了他们的皮质醇，并且实际上在全天都具有持久的影响。艾莉森，谈谈为什么会发生这种情况。为什么对我们来说表达
our positive emotions, not just feel them? I think that when we express emotions to other people, part of what happens is that we're creating a shared reality about them, right? We are not just experiencing them by ourselves, but experiencing them with other people, and that can make them feel more real. And I think it's also the case that sometimes as we go through our lives, you know, we take the people around us a bit for granted and we feel like, you know, I can tell them all the negative things that are happening,
我们的积极情绪很重要，而不仅仅是感受它们？我认为，当我们向他人表达情绪时，发生的一部分事情是我们正在围绕它们创造一个共享的现实，对吧？我们不仅仅是独自体验它们，而是与其他人一起体验，这会使它们感觉更加真实。我认为情况也是如此，有时随着我们经历生活，你知道，我们有点认为身边的人是理所当然的，并且我们觉得，你知道，我可以告诉他们所有正在发生的负面事情，
all the things that I'm unhappy about in my life, and we forget to tell them about things that are positive that are going on in our lives. And of course, that's not a good way to spread positivity or to increase the net positivity in the relationship. Yes, and there's actually research showing
我生活中所有我不高兴的事情，我们却忘记了告诉他们我们生活中正在发生的积极事情。当然，这不是传播积极性或增加关系中净积极性的好方法。是的，实际上有研究表明
that capitalizing, that's what researchers call it. So celebrating positives with friends and people who are close to us is also very important. So we think about, like, our friends are so important for supporting us when something goes wrong.
资本化，研究人员就是这么称呼它的。因此，与朋友和亲近的人庆祝积极的事情也非常重要。所以我们认为，比如我们的朋友在事情出错时对我们的支持非常重要。
But it's also really important that we have to, people around us who can get excited for us when things go well. I'm wondering whether you follow this advice yourself. Do you take a couple of minutes every day to write down the great things that are happening in your life or to share positive things that are happening with other people, Alison? As with probably everyone, I'm much better at giving advice than following it myself. But I have tried at various points in my life to do the gratitude journaling.
但同样非常重要的一点是，当事情进展顺利时，我们需要周围有人能为我们感到兴奋。我想知道你是否自己遵循这个建议。艾莉森，你是否每天花几分钟写下你生活中正在发生的美好事情，或者与其他人分享正在发生的积极事情？可能和每个人一样，我总是很擅长给别人建议，但自己却很难做到。不过我在生活中的不同阶段都尝试过做感恩日记。
and sharing positives with other people. So there was one period of time that I was feeling just really down about everything and realized that I was looking on the negative side of things very habitually. And I decided to try writing for a few minutes every evening about things that were positive, things that I appreciated that I felt grateful for. And at first, it was very difficult. I would just stare at this blank sheet of paper for like three minutes or however long I set the timer on my phone. And then the timer would ring and I would be all grumpy and I'd write down dog, right? I guess.
并且与其他人分享积极的事情。所以有一段时间，我对所有事情都感到非常沮丧，并意识到自己非常习惯于看事情消极的一面。我决定尝试每天晚上写几分钟积极的事情，那些我欣赏的、让我感到感激的事情。一开始，这非常困难。我会盯着这张白纸大约三分钟，或者不管我在手机上设置了多长时间的计时器。然后计时器响了，我会很不高兴，然后我会写下“狗”，对吧？我猜。
As in you're grateful for your dog? That was the one thing you could think of. Yeah, it was the one, but it wasn't accompanied. I want to be clear. It was not accompanied by like feelings of gratitude. I was mad at myself for making myself do the task. And I was basically saying like, technically my dog's not bad, I guess. And after a few days of that, it was definitely multiple days, right? I think I thought of a second example and started feeling slightly more appreciative of the dog. I mean, the dog was great throughout, right? The dog's a dog. The dog's happy to see me. The dog's lovely. It's not her fault. But I started thinking like, oh, the dog and the way the dog smiles when I come home. And then a few days after that, it starts getting even easier. And I have maybe
意思是说你感激你的狗？那是你能想到的唯一一件事。是的，这是唯一的一件，但它并没有伴随着。我想明确一点。它并没有伴随着那种感激的情感。我为自己逼自己做这项任务而生姜。我基本上是在说，从技术上讲，我的狗并不坏，我想。经过几天的这种情况，这绝对是好几天，对吧？我想我想到了第二个例子，开始对这只狗多了一点感激之情。我的意思是，这只狗一直都很棒，对吧？狗就是狗。这只狗很高兴看到我。这只狗很可爱。这不是她的错。但我开始觉得，哦，这只狗，以及我回家时狗微笑的方式。然后在那之后的几天里，它开始变得更容易了。我有好几句
several sentences of things that I feel appreciation for. And then what I noticed over the course of a couple weeks is that I started thinking of those little things during the day, not just when I sat down in the evening to do it intentionally, right? But it had become a more habitual style of thinking. So in some ways you're starting to notice things because in some ways you're making yourself notice things. Right. It starts out intentional.
我欣赏的事物的好几句话。然后我注意到的是，在几周的时间里，我开始在白天想到这些小事，而不仅仅是在晚上坐下来故意这样做的时候，对吧？但这已经成为了一种更习惯的思考方式。所以在某些方面，你开始注意到事物，因为在某些方面你强迫自己注意到事物。对。它一开始是有意的。
It starts out. I'm walking in a new way to work, and I have to pay attention and turn right on this street and think of how my dog is actually a positive thing in my life. And then with practice, it gets easier. With practice, it becomes almost effortless and automatic in other parts of your day. Now, please tell me that you have thought positive thoughts, not just about your dog, but there are other things in your life that you also think are positive. This is true. There are other things in my life that I also think are positive. It reminds me, Alison, that the way you're describing this, this feels so much like the way exercise works. You know, the first day we do it, we're groaning and we're just really reluctant and we're like, do I have to do this? And you don't like doing this and you don't do very much of it. But, of course, if you do it for a week and you do it for two weeks and you do it for a month, it starts to get progressively easier. And then you start to find new things that you'd like to do, new forms of exercise.
它开始了。我以一种新的方式走去上班，我必须注意并在这条街上右转，想想我的狗实际上是我生活中的积极事物。然后通过练习，它变得更容易了。通过练习，在你的白天的其他时间里，它变得几乎毫不费力和自动化。现在，请告诉我，你不仅对你的狗有过积极的想法，而且你的生活中还有其他你也认为是积极的事情。这是真的。我的生活中还有其他我也认为是积极的事情。这让我想起，艾莉森，你描述这一点的方式，这感觉太像锻炼的工作方式了。你知道，我们做的第一天，我们在呻吟，我们真的很勉强，我们就像，我必须这样做吗？你不喜欢这样做，你也不会做太多。但是，当然，如果你做了一个星期，做了两个星期，做了一个月，它开始变得越来越容易。然后你开始发现你喜欢做的新事情，新的锻炼形式。
And they just sort of build on one another. Yes, so you're exercising a new thought pattern instead of like a physical muscle. And as you do it, it gets easier and easier. So, Alison, I understand that people in your life sometimes point out that you don't always practice what you preach in terms of focusing on the positive. Plenty of people call me out when I am hypocritical about something, which I appreciate very much. My partner actually had this lovely practice when we first got together of celebrating successes when we're both academics. So this is probably not unique to academia, but we're both academics. And every success that we have is partial, is a little step towards the ultimate goal.
它们只是互相叠加。是的，所以你是在锻炼一个新的思维模式，而不是像一个身体肌肉。当你这样做的时候，它变得越来越容易。所以，艾莉森，据我了解，你生活中的人们有时会指出，你在专注于积极方面时并不总是说到做到。很多人在我对某事虚伪时指出来，我非常感激。我的伴侣实际上在我们刚在一起时有一个可爱的习惯，就是庆祝成功，我们俩都是学者。所以这可能不是学术界所特有的，但我们俩都是学者。我们取得的每一个成功都是局部的，是朝着最终目标迈出的一小步。
You don't get a paper accepted. You write the paper and you submit it and then it gets rejected and then you revise it and you submit it again. And then you get requests for revision and then you make the revision. Right. It's it's this long process. My partner had this delightful habit when we got together of celebrating each stage in the process, each time you take a little step towards your goal with a special dinner. So I submitted the paper. I got a special. dinner. I submitted a revision of the paper. I get a special dinner. I got feedback. I get a special dinner. And we've adopted this together because it both helps keep your attention on the positive, right, instead of it getting lost in your day, because, annoyingly, we never get to have a day that's just one success and nothing else happens, right? There's always something. So if you return to it in the evening, then it helps kind of pull that part of your day out for you and highlight it. And once again, you're sharing it with somebody else. So you're creating this shared reality about it and celebrating it together.
你没有发表一篇论文。你写了这篇论文并提交了它，然后它被拒绝了，然后你修改了它并再次提交。然后你收到了修改的要求，然后你做出了修改。对，这是一个漫长的过程。我的伴侣在我们在一起时有一个令人愉快的习惯，即庆祝这个过程中的每一个阶段，每次你朝着你的目标迈出一小步时，都会有一顿特别的晚餐。所以我提交了这篇论文。我得到了一个特别的晚餐。我提交了论文的修改版。我吃了一顿特别的晚餐。我得到了反馈。我得到了一个特别的晚餐。我们一起采用了这一点，因为它既有助于将你的注意力集中在积极的方面，对吧，而不是让它迷失在你的日常生活中，因为讨厌的是，我们永远不会有一天只是一个成功而没有其他事情发生，对吧？总会有一些事情。因此，如果你在晚上回到它身边，那么它有助于为你把那部分一天的生活拉出来并突出它。再一次，你正在与其他人分享它。所以你正在围绕它创造一个共同的现实并一起庆祝它。
Another approach you advise people to take is to engage in what you call gain framing. What is gain framing, Alison? Gain framing is just what we've been calling positive framing. So one thing I like to do is when I make mistake, it usually feels bad. I perseverate on it. I think of all the things I wish had happened so that I wouldn't have made the mistake. But then if I can reframe the mistake in my mind as a learning opportunity, it doesn't get rid of all the bad feelings, right? But it focuses my attention on, okay, what can I do differently next time? And I'm kind of putting that energy into creating a new
你建议人们采取的另一种方法是参与你所说的收益框架。什么是收益框架，艾莉森？收益框架就是我们一直在说的积极框架。所以我想做的一件事是，当我犯错误时，它通常感觉很糟糕。我对此念念不忘。我想到了我希望发生的所有事情，这样我就不会犯错误了。但是，如果我能在脑海中将这个错误重新定义为一个学习机会，它并不能消除所有的坏感觉，对吧？但它将我的注意力集中在，好吧，下次我能做些什么不同的事情？我有点把这种能量投入到创造一个新
plan for the future. Alison, you have a co-author, a political scientist with whom you have collaborated on a number of projects, and at one point recently, the two of you felt like you had become participants in your own research. Tell me what happened. So my colleague Amber Boydston, here in the Political Science Department at UC Davis, was working with me on just starting this research, and we applied for a grant to fund it. So we write the grant proposal, which is long and hard.
未来的计划中。艾莉森，你有一位合著者，是一位政治学家，你曾与他合作过多个项目，最近在某个时候，你们两个觉得你们已经成为了自己研究的参与者。告诉我发生了什么。所以我的同事Amber Boydston，这里加州大学戴维斯分校政治学系的同事，和我一起刚开始这项研究，我们申请了一笔资助来资助它。所以我们写了资助提案，这又长又难。
We submit it. We wait for months and months to hear back. And finally, one day, we get an email back with a decision. So we hold our breath and cross all our fingers and pose and anything else we can find. And we open it up. And it says our grant has been funded. And we get maybe two seconds of unadulterated joy until we read the next sentence, which says, unfortunately, we had to cut your funding by half.
我们提交了它。我们等待了几个月又几个月以听到消息。最后，有一天，我们收到了一封带决定的一封电子邮件。所以我们屏住呼吸，交叉所有的手指，摆好姿势，以及我们能找到的任何其他东西。我们打开了它。上面说我们的资助已经得到了资助。我们得到了大约两秒钟的毫无保留的快乐，直到我们读了下一句，上面说，不幸的是，我们不得不将你们的资助削减一半。
And we were so disappointed that we lost half of our funding. And we're just sitting there feeling so bad about it. And then we go, wait, wait, but we got half of our funding. Wait, are we participants in our own study here? Yeah, because the pleasure of having the grant was stolen almost immediately by the fact that the grant was not what you expected. But of course, it hasn't stolen the entire pleasure, or at least it shouldn't. It shouldn't at all. We were still able to do a large portion of the research with the half of the grant that we got. And two minutes before that, right, we hadn't had a grant at all. So we almost literally got a half full glass, but immediately focused on the part that was empty. That makes me think about one thing that I think happens to a lot of people, which is that when good things happen to us, we tend to absorb them fairly quickly. And then they become part of the background. They become part of the wall.
我们非常失望，我们失去了我们一半的资助。我们只是坐在那里，对此感到非常糟糕。然后我们说，等等，等等，但是我们得到了我们一半的资助。等等，我们这里是我们自己的研究的参与者吗？是的，因为拥有资助的快乐几乎立即被资助不如你预期的事实所偷走了。但是，当然，它并没有偷走所有的快乐，或者至少它不应该。它一点也不应该。我们仍然能够用我们获得的半笔资助完成很大一部分研究。在那之前的两分钟，对吧，我们根本没有资助。所以我们几乎字面意义上得到了一个半满的杯子，但立即专注于空的那部分。这让我想起了一件我认为发生在很多人身上的事情，那就是当好事发生在我们身上时，我们往往会相当快地吸收它们。然后它们变成了背景的一部分。它们变成了墙壁的一部分。
wallpaper, if you will. And so, you know, a second before you open this, the news to discover that you got the grant, you would have given a lot to know that you got the grant. It would have made you so happy. But the moment you know that you got the grant, that sort of slips away into the background and everything else, including the fact that the grant was cut in half, that comes into the foreground. Yes. And you know, there's this really interesting research on how easily we adapt to our current circumstances. So we love. level set to whatever the current reality is, the current status quo. And I think this is one of those cases where we can adapt very quickly to a positive
壁纸，如果你愿意的话。所以，你知道，在你打开这个的前一秒，这个消息发现你得到了资助，你会付出很多来知道你得到了资助。这会让你非常高兴。但当你得知你得到资助的那一刻，那种感觉就滑入背景中，其他一切，包括资助被削减了一半的事实，都来到了前景中。是的。你知道，关于我们如何轻松地适应当前环境，有一项非常有趣的研究。所以我们热爱。无论当前的现实、当前的现状是什么，我们都将其平准化。我认为这是我们可以非常快速地适应积极事物的情况之一
and maybe not quite so quickly to a negative. You recently had an experience where you made an effort to celebrate the positive. I understand it made a real difference. Can you tell me what happened? So in our house, we put everyone's successes on the fridge so that we can celebrate each other's positives and feel better about them ourselves. So a couple weeks ago, my kid got an award at school. And of course, that goes on the fridge. I guess that's pretty normal to put it on the fridge. But we also try to notice it and mention it to each other when we walk by. And in our house,
也许对消极事物没有那么快。你最近经历了一次经历，你努力去庆祝积极的事情。据我了解，这确实带来了不同。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？所以在我们家里，我们把每个人的成功都贴在冰箱上，这样我们就可以庆祝彼此的积极事物，并对它们本身感觉更好。所以几周前，我的孩子在学校得了一个奖。当然，这贴在了冰箱上。我想把它贴在冰箱上是很正常的。但我们也试图注意到它，当我们走过时互相提一下。在我们家里，
grown-up successes go up on the fridge too, so that when I have a success or when my partner has a success, that goes up there too. And so, for example, my partner comes home yesterday. So he has written a book on relationships that's coming out soon. And yesterday he came home from recording the audiobook. And he tells me that the director there said that it was one of the best readings he had ever heard. And then my partner turns away to go on with his day and do the other 63 things that he has to do, right? And I'm like, no, stop. First of all, that's amazing.
成年人的成功也贴在冰箱上，这样当我取得成功或我的伙伴取得成功时，它也会贴上去。所以，例如，我的伙伴昨天回家了。所以他写了一本关于关系的书，即将出版。昨天他从录制有声书回家。他告诉我那里的导演说这是他听过的最好的朗读之一。然后我的伙伴转过身去继续他的一天，做其他62事情他必须要做的事情，对吧？我说，不，停下来。首先，这太棒了。
That's an amazing thing for somebody to tell you. And second, go write that down. Right now, print it out. We're putting it up on the fridge. and we're going to talk about it every time I walk by. Let's talk a moment about the role that we play in bringing positivity or negativity into the lives of other people, Alison. Very often, I think, when someone is rude to us, when we are having a bad day, we may have a tendency to pass on this negativity to others. So in some ways, you know, negativity begets more negativity.
对于某人来说，这是一件了不起的事情。第二，去把它写下来。现在，把它打印出来。我们要把它贴在冰箱上。每次我走过去，我们都要谈论它。让我们花一会儿时间来谈谈我们在给其他人的生活带来积极性或消极性方面所扮演的角色，艾莉森。很多时候，我认为，当有人对我们无礼，当我们度过糟糕的一天时，我们可能会有一种倾向，将这种消极情绪传递给其他人。所以在某些方面，你知道，消极情绪会孕育更多的消极情绪。
Are there ways to interrupt this cascade? I think so. You know, every now and then, I manage to do this. in the middle of a fight with my partner or my kid, I see a way to be silly or make a joke. And then suddenly we can laugh together instead of being stuck in this negative spiral. So a few weeks ago, we were having a family dinner and we had just washed the tablecloth. And my kid kept spilling little things on the table. She'd spill like a little bit of a sauce or one noodle, right?
有没有办法打断这种连锁反应？我想是的。你知道，每隔一段时间，我设法做到这一点。在与我的伙伴或孩子的争吵中，我看到了一种变得愚蠢或开玩笑的方法。然后突然我们可以一起笑，而不是陷入这个消极的漩涡中。所以几周前，我们正在吃家庭晚餐，我们刚刚洗了桌布。我的孩子一直在桌子上洒小东西。她会洒一点酱汁或一根面条，对吧？
And my partner and I would rush to clean it up. and we're all getting kind of more and more stressed about trying to keep a tablecloth clean so that we don't have to do laundry again. And suddenly I just had this impulse. So I picked up a big handful of what we were having for dinner and I just slapped it down on the tablecloth. So there's this huge mess everywhere. And I'm like, I guess we're doing laundry and we all get to laugh about it, right, instead of being kind of sniping at each other and stuck in this negative space. Yeah. I think it's sometimes hard when people treat us badly, when we are the recipients of negativity,
我和我的伙伴会冲过去清理它。我们都对试图保持桌布清洁感到越来越压力，这样我们就不必再次洗衣服了。突然我有了这种冲动。所以我抓了一大把我们晚餐吃的东西，直接拍在桌布上。所以到处都是一团糟。我说，我想我们要洗衣服了，我们都可以对此笑一笑，对吧，而不是互相冷嘲热讽并陷入这个消极的空间。是的。我认为有时当人们对我们不好，当我们成为消极情绪的接受者时，这是很难的
to respond with something that is not negativity. You know, psychologists have long talked about the norm of reciprocity. You know, we are kind when we're treated kindly. We are rude when we're treated rudely. But really, I think what you're pointing to or what you're recommending is that we are kind when we're treated rudely. That's not easy to do. It's not easy at all. And to be clear, I usually don't.
用不是消极情绪的东西来回应。你知道，心理学家长期以来一直在谈论互惠规范。你知道，当别人对我们友善时，我们是友善的。当别人对我们无礼时，我们是无礼的。但实际上，我认为你所指出的或你所推荐的是，当别人对我们无礼时，我们是友善的。这并不容易做到。这根本不容易。而且要明确的是，我通常不会这样做。
But I think we can try. right? And then every now and then there's this little window of opportunity that we get to interrupt that negative cycle. I'm wondering after having done all of this work on the negativity bias, do you feel like you yourself are able to be less negative as you go through your life, Alison? I think the answer to that probably depends on the day. Some days I'm doing it pretty well. And some days I'm not. And that's okay. But really what helps me is to think about these two pieces together. There's what is the negative focus telling me? How can I use anger or negativity to fuel me? I try to think about bad mood as information.
但我认为我们可以尝试，对吧？然后每隔一段时间，就会有这样一个小的机会窗口，我们可以打断那个消极的循环。我想知道在做了所有这些关于消极偏差的工作之后，你是否觉得你自己能够在度过生活时减少消极情绪，艾莉森？我想这个问题的答案可能取决于那天。有些天我做得很好。有些天我没有。没关系。但真正对我有帮助的是把这两部分放在一起考虑。消极焦点在告诉我什么？我如何利用愤怒或消极情绪来推动自己？我试着把坏心情视为信息。
It's a messenger. It's saying something is wrong. and then also how can I balance out that negativity with some positives in my own life? Rebalancing negative emotions with positive emotions can be powerful. Paying attention to the good things in our lives can help us remember what we have stopped noticing. It can remind us that there are silver linings to life's problems. But there are certain situations where the intensity of a negative emotion can make it very hard to see anything positive. The dark cloud hides the silver lining.
它是一个信使。它在说有什么不对劲。然后还有我如何用我生活中的一些积极情绪来平衡这种消极情绪？用积极情绪重新平衡消极情绪可能很有力量。关注我们生活中的美好事物可以帮助我们记住我们已经停止注意的事情。它能提醒我们，生活的问题也有光明的一面。但在某些情况下，消极情绪的强度会让人很难看到任何积极的东西。乌云遮住了银边。
Let me tell you a story we received from a listener named Chris. Chris used to spend her days working in one of the most beautiful, all-inspiring places in the world. I used to work as a river guide in the Grand Canyon for a long time, and we used to do kind of team building, group building, fun things all day long. After planning the waters of the canyon all day, the group would gather around the campfire for one life, bonding activity before they went to sleep. As the stars twinkled above them in the inky night sky,
让我给你讲一个我们从一个叫克里斯的听众那里收到的故事。克里斯过去常常在世界上最美丽、令人敬畏的地方之一工作。我过去曾在科罗拉多大峡谷担任河道向导很长时间，我们过去常常一整天都在进行团队建设、团队建设、有趣的事情。在峡谷的水域规划了一整天之后，团队会在睡觉前聚在营地篝火旁进行一次生命、凝聚力的活动。当星星在墨黑的夜空中闪烁时，
we would floss our teeth together. They would floss their teeth together. And that's not all. Perhaps you're picturing 20 people standing around and simultaneously flossing their teeth. Uh-uh. That's not what happened. I mean, everybody, you can have up to 20 people flossing their teeth with the same piece of dental floss.
我们会一起用牙线清洁牙齿。他们会一起用牙线清洁牙齿。还不止这些。也许你在脑海中想象20个人站在一起，同时用牙线清洁牙齿。呃-呃。事情不是这样的。我的意思是，每个人，你最多可以有20个人用同一段牙线用牙线清洁牙齿。
The same piece of dental floss. Now, before you lose your lunch or call the dental police on Chris, there's an asterisk that makes the story less unsettling. Slightly less unsettling. I don't mean everybody sharing that from one person to the next, but you take a new spool of dental floss and stretch it out as far as it will go. So you each get your own clean, untouched little section. but everybody's flossing with the same piece at the same time.
同一段牙线。现在，在你恶心得吃不下饭或给克里斯叫牙医警察之前，有一个星号让这个故事不那么令人不安。稍微不那么令人不安。我的意思不是每个人从一个人到另一个人分享那个，而是你拿一个新的一卷牙线，把它拉长到尽可能长的距离。所以你们每个人都得到自己干净的、未被触碰的小部分。但每个人都在同时用同一段牙线清洁。
So imagine a long string of floss, maybe 30 feet long. Your section of the dental floss is clean and unspoiled. You can see that. But inches from you is someone else pulling on the same string, getting inside their gums. Would you grab your piece of string and floss away with gusto? When I think about that now or when I tell somebody else about that now, they are disgusted. Even though you know that nobody else has touched your piece,
所以想象一下一根长长的牙线，也许有30英尺长。你的那段牙线是干净且未受破坏的。你可以看到这一点。但离你几英寸远的是另一个人在拉同一根弦，进入他们的牙龈。你会抓住你的那段弦并兴高采烈地用牙线清洁吗？我现在想到这一点，或者现在向别人讲述这一点时，他们会感到厌恶。即使你知道没有其他人碰过你的那段，
of dental floss. It's pretty funny, how it's clean, but it's still disgusting. I'm guessing that if you find the story disgusting, thinking about all the beautiful stars in the night sky over the Grand Canyon will not help. In the early days of Hidden Brain, I often describe myself as a card-carrying rationalist. Since then, however, I've learned the endless ways in which humans can be anything but rational. Our visceral response to things we perceive as disgusting is a prime example. Logic and our own eyes may tell us that something is safe and clean, but our emotions can tell us a very different story.
牙线。这挺搞笑的，它是干净的，但它仍然很恶心。我猜如果你觉得这个故事很恶心，想想科罗拉多大峡谷夜空中所有美丽的星星是没有帮助的。在隐秘大脑的早期，我经常将自己描述为一个持证的理性主义者。然而，从那时起，我了解到了人类可能不是理性的无数方式。我们对我们认为是恶心的事物的本能反应就是一个典型的例子。逻辑和我们自己的眼睛可能会告诉我们某事是安全和干净的，但我们的情感可以告诉我们一个完全不同的故事。
When we come back, remarkable stories of revulsion. We'll delve into the icky and endlessly fascinating science of disgust. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. What do you find disgusting? Cockroaches, mouldy food, your kids' stinky gym socks? We each have our own lists of things that revolt us and our own internal barometers for how easily we are disgusted by things that are rotten, smelly or diseased. That's part of what makes disgust so fascinating. It's driven by a combination of emotions, reflexes, and cultural cues. We recently
当我们回来时，引人注目的反感故事。我们将深入探讨恶心和无尽迷人的恶心科学。你正在收听的是隐秘大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是隐秘大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你觉得什么很恶心？蟑螂、发霉的食物、你孩子的发臭的健身袜？我们每个人都有自己的让我们感到反感的清单，以及我们对被腐烂、发臭或生病的事物感到恶心的容易程度的自己的内部气压计。这正是让恶心如此迷人的部分原因。它是由情感、反射和文化线索的结合驱动的。我们最近
talked about all this with David Pizarro. He's a psychologist at Cornell University, and he joined us for an episode titled, Yuck, the Science of Disgust. Listeners had many stories and questions that they shared in response to that conversation, and David returns to the show today to discuss them. David Pizarro, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Thank you for having me again. David, one of the striking things about disgust is that it spreads. It contaminates other things. things. The fly that is sitting on the slice of toast makes the toast inedible. Why do disgusting things seem to infect other things? It's a great question and it's often been observed about disgust that, you know, one fly on your toast ruins the toast, but one piece of toast on a group
与大卫·皮扎罗讨论了所有这些。他是康奈尔大学的心理学家，他加入了我们的一集名为“哎呀，恶心的科学”。听众们分享了许多故事和问题，以回应那次对话，大卫今天重返节目来讨论它们。大卫·皮扎罗，欢迎回到隐秘大脑。谢谢。谢谢你再次邀请我。大卫，关于恶心的一个引人注目的事情是它会蔓延。它会污染其他事物。事物。停在吐司片上的苍蝇使吐司无法食用。为什么恶心的事物似乎会感染其他事物？这是一个很好的问题，人们经常对恶心观察到这一点，你知道，你吐司上的一只苍蝇毁了吐司，但一群苍蝇上的一片吐司
of flies does not somehow cleanse the flies. And the thought is that because discussed, it is widely believed is an emotion that evolved to keep us from getting sick long before humans had any sort of germ theory of disease. Disgust, nonetheless, was tracking contagion. And so disgust seems to be the one emotion that works via this kind of contagion process. Many listeners wanted to learn more about why some of us tolerate things better than others. Here's Veronica from Michigan. Please, tell me more about why I'm able to. to go pick up roadkill on the side of the road and complete weirdo things like taxidermy projects or bone articulation projects, whereas my peers just sort of recoil in horror and probably
并没有以某种方式清洁苍蝇。人们的想法是，因为恶心，人们普遍认为这是一种进化而来的情绪，旨在让我们在人类拥有任何疾病细菌理论之前很久就远离疾病。尽管如此，恶心一直在追踪传染。因此，恶心似乎是通过这种传染过程起作用的唯一情绪。许多听众想了解更多关于为什么我们中的一些人比其他人更能容忍事物的原因。这里是来自密歇根州的维罗妮卡。请告诉我更多关于为什么我能够。去路边捡路杀，完成一些奇怪的怪事，比如剥制术项目或骨骼关节项目，而我的同龄人只是惊恐地退缩，可能
judgment when I tell them about this hobby. Thanks so much. So David, is there something special about people like Veronica? Well, there is something different about people like Veronica, but there might be one of two things that's different. Veronica might be over. Veronica might be overall less likely to be disgusted in general at a whole bunch of different things. Or Veronica might have gotten used to specifically those projects that she referred to. So we can get used to doing things. Anybody who's had to clean toilets, you know, knows that it might be the grossest thing you do the first time you do it. But after a while, you just have to get used to it. And so we can develop very domain-specific adaptation to disgust. But Veronica might be one of those people who is just on that
当我告诉他们这个爱好时，会有所评判。非常感谢。所以大卫，像维罗妮卡这样的人有什么特别之处吗？嗯，像维罗妮卡这样的人确实有些不同，但可能会有两件不同的事情之一。维罗妮卡可能过度。维罗妮卡总体上可能在对一大堆不同的事情总体上不太可能感到恶心。或者维罗妮卡可能已经习惯了她所提到的那些特定的项目。所以我们可以习惯做事情。任何不得不打扫厕所的人，你知道，都知道这可能是你第一次做时最恶心的事情。但过了一会儿，你只需要习惯它。因此，我们可以对恶心发展出非常特定领域的适应。但维罗妮卡可能是那些人之一，她只是在那个
end of the distribution that, who just isn't bothered in general by lots of disgusting things. We talked in our earlier discussion about how love and lust can temporarily mute our disgust responses. So you might find another child's soil diaper disgusting, but you don't find your own baby's soil diaper disgusting. You might not want to share someone's dental floss, but you're willing to lock your mouth on someone else's mouth if you're in love. Why is this, David? Well, you know, this is speculation. Whenever we talk about evolved mechanisms, we can't go back in evolutionary time and look, but it is thought that if there is one time where it is important to not feel too much disgust at what you're doing, it would be during that time when we engage in reproductive activities. Because
分布的末端，对许多恶心的事物总体上并不感到困扰。我们在之前的讨论中谈到了爱和欲望如何暂时削弱我们的恶心反应。所以你可能会发现另一个孩子的弄脏的尿布很恶心，但你不会发现你自己的婴儿的弄脏的尿布很恶心。你可能不想分享某人的牙线，但如果你恋爱了，你愿意把你的嘴锁在别人的嘴上。这是为什么，大卫？嗯，你知道，这是推测。每当我们谈论进化机制时，我们无法回到进化时间并看一眼，但人们认为，如果有一个时间对于对你正在做的事情感觉不太恶心很重要，那就是在我们进行生殖活动的时候。因为
As I say sometimes to my students, if you thought about what you were doing in the moment, you probably wouldn't want to do it. And so it's important to be able to turn off that little switch. And I think that the same goes for having to take care of people we love. We received an interesting question from listener Laurie about people who are more sensitive to disgust. I just listened to your episode on disgust, and I found it really interesting. and couldn't help but maybe compare those who display discussed to also being individuals that demonstrate high preferences on everything from toilet paper to how a spouse looks or beyond.
正如我有时对我的学生所说的那样，如果你当时考虑你正在做的事情，你可能不会想去做。所以能够关闭那个小开关很重要。我认为照顾我们爱的人也是如此。我们收到了听众劳里的一个有趣的问题，关于那些对恶心更敏感的人。我刚刚听了你关于恶心的那一集，我发现它真的很有趣。并且不禁将那些表现出恶心的人与那些在从厕所纸到配偶长相或超越的一切方面表现出高度偏好的个人进行比较。
So, yeah, I was interested to know if there is a correlation and what that might be. I appreciate your show so much. What do you think, David? Is there any research showing that people who are highly sensitive to disgust are also more particular or even more controlling in other dimensions of their lives? It's a great question that Lori asks. And the answer is a little bit unclear. And I'll say why.
所以，是的，我有兴趣知道是否存在相关性以及它可能是什么。非常感谢你的节目。你觉得怎么样，大卫？有没有任何研究表明，对恶心高度敏感的人在他们生活的其他方面也更挑剔甚至更具控制欲？这是劳里提出的一个很好的问题。答案有点不清楚。我会说为什么。
It depends on what kind of disgust you're talking about. So some people do distinguish between moral disgust, sexual disgust, or what they call pathogen discussed, the thing that I've been talking about the most, the thing that keeps you away from disease. And when you look at other personality traits, it seems as if there is not a whole lot of correlation between the tendency to feel grossed out in the pathogen discussed way. and personality traits that might be similar to controllingness. There is a little bit of an effect such that people who are high in Machiavellianism, which is a trait that you might consider an extreme form of controlling,
这取决于你谈论的是哪种有些。所以有些人确实区分了道德恶心、性恶心，或者他们所说的病原体恶心，我一直在谈论最多的事情，让你远离疾病的事情。当你查看其他人格特征时，似乎在病原体恶心的方式下感到恶心的倾向与可能类似于控制欲的人格特征之间没有太多的相关性。确实有一点影响，即马基雅维利主义得分高的人，这是一种你可能认为是极端控制形式的特征，
that is a desire to control others for your own gain. And that actually shows a negative, although small correlation with disgust. And so there's not a whole lot that is, I would say, is demonstrating a strong relationship between disgust sensitivity and some of these other personality variables. And when you say there's an inverse correlation between Machiavellianism and disgust, you're saying that people who are low in disgust are high in Machiavellian tendencies? That's right. That's right. Or people, yes, you could say people who are easily discussed that are less likely to be maccabalian.
这是一种为了你自己的利益而控制他人的欲望。这实际上显示了一种负面，尽管很小的与恶心的相关性。因此，没有多少东西，我会说，证明了恶心敏感性与其中一些其他人格变量之间存在强烈的关系。当你说马基雅维利主义和恶心之间存在反比相关性时，你是说恶心得分低的人具有很高的马基雅维利倾向？没错。没错。或者人们，是的，你可以说容易恶心的人不太可能是马基雅维利主义者。
We talked in our earlier conversation about the role of smell in eliciting feelings of disgust. Listener, Emily, had a question about a different sense and its impact on our experience of disgust. Apropos of your show on disgust, I would like to pose the question of visual disgust, not just smell, but there's sometimes when I see patterns of repeated shapes. It could be a bunch of pebbles or a way things are put together, but more often it resembles like a swarm, a swarm of bugs. I just feel such a visceral sense of repulsion that I could throw up. Any comments about that? That is a great question, Emily.
我们在之前的对话中谈到了气味在引发恶心感方面的作用。听众艾米丽对一种不同的感官及其对我们恶心体验的影响有一个问题。关于你关于恶心的节目，我想提出视觉恶心的的问题，不仅仅是气味，但有时当我看到重复形状的图案时。它可能是一堆卵石或事物组合在一起的方式，但更常见的是它类似于一群虫子，一群虫子。我只是感到一种如此本能的排斥感，以至于我可以呕吐。对此有什么评论吗？这是一个很好的问题，艾米丽。
There are quite a few people who report the kind of disgust reaction that you're reporting. In fact, it has a name, tripophobia. Tripophobia is a disgust response to small holes, patterns, bumps that occur sort of in a regular pattern, as Emily was describing. And it seems as if maybe there is an evolved evolutionary explanation for why we might have them, because there's an association between those kinds of patterns and maybe be some diseases that are visible on the skin. But that is speculation. But I want to tell Emily that she's definitely not alone and she definitely should not Google the word tripophobia.
有相当多的人报告了你所报告的那种恶心反应。事实上，它有一个名字，密集恐惧症。密集恐惧症是对小洞、图案、以某种常规图案出现的小疙瘩的恶心反应，正如艾米丽所描述的那样。并且似乎可能有一个进化的进化解释，为什么我们可能会有它们，因为这些类型的图案与皮肤上可见的一些疾病之间存在关联。但这只是推测。但我想告诉艾米丽，她绝对不是一个人，她绝对不应该在谷歌上搜索密集恐惧症这个词。
It strikes me as you're describing this, David, that it might be that it's not just that we differ from other people when it comes to disgust. It also might be that each of us has different sensitivities when it comes to our different senses. So some of us might be more prone to disgust that comes to us through our noses and others might be more disgusted by something that we touch. I think that's exactly right. And there is some research showing that women have a lower threshold for olfactory stimuli that might make them disgusted. And there are ways to measure that threshold. you give people sort of increasing doses of a smell and you can chart them to see where they are
当你描述这一点时，大卫，这让我觉得，可能不仅是我们与其他人不同，当谈到恶心时。这也可能是我们每个人在面对不同感官时都有不同的敏感性。所以我们中的一些人可能更容易对通过鼻子传来的恶心感到倾向，而另一些人可能对我们触摸到的东西更感到恶心。我认为这完全正确。并且有一些研究表明，女性对可能让她们感到恶心的嗅觉刺激的阈值较低。并且有办法测量该阈值。你给人们某种程度上不断增加剂量的气味，你可以绘制图表来看看他们在哪里
on how sensitive they are to smells. And it seems as if women have a particular sensitivity to disgust smells. There's another thing that's very interesting about smell specifically as compared to vision. Smell is one of the senses that has a much more direct path to our emotions. It sort of bypasses a lot of the,
关于他们对气味的敏感度。并且女性似乎对恶心的气味具有特殊的敏感度。与视觉相比，气味本身还有一个非常有趣的地方。气味是通往我们情绪的最直接路径之一。它有点绕过了许多
the areas of the brain that other sensory inputs get processed through. And that's why some people, you know, will report that they get an immediate sense of nostalgia when they smell something or they're transported to a memory of an old girlfriend or boyfriend when they smell a perfume or cologne. And disgust is very strong in that olfactory sense as well. The sight of feces does not do as good a job as good a job as, the smell of feces in inducing disgust. Listener, Lisa, sent us a question
其他感觉输入所处理的脑区。这就是为什么有些人，你知道，会报告说当他们闻到某种东西时，他们会立即产生一种怀旧感，或者当他们闻到某种香水或古龙水时，他们会被带回到前女友或前男友的记忆中。恶心在那个人嗅觉感官中也非常强烈。粪便的视觉效果不如粪便的气味那样能很好地引发恶心。听众丽莎给我们发了一个问题
highlighting how we can often have a different bar for what we consider disgusting based on whether it's us or someone else doing the thing in question. I wonder why when I do certain personal things like lick icing off my finger, it's fine. But when another family member does it, I find it extremely disgusting.
强调了我们如何根据是我们还是其他人做这件事，对我们认为恶心的东西有不同的标准。我想知道为什么当我做某些个人事情时，比如舔掉手指上的糖霜，这很好。但当另一个家庭成员这样做时，我发现它极其恶心。
So just thought I'd throw that into the hopper for your consideration. So it seems like our capacity for disgust has a great deal of hypocrisy woven into it, David. Yes, I think Lisa has discovered this very, very deep part of human psychology, which is when other people do things, it's worse than when we do them. there are things that are not disgusting because it is us. It is part of us. Our bodily fluids, our bodily processes. Another thing is that you can't see yourself doing it.
所以只是想把这个扔进漏斗里供你考虑。所以看起来我们的恶心能力中编织了大量的虚伪，大卫。是的，我认为丽莎发现了人类心理学中非常非常深的一部分，那就是当其他人做事情时，这比我们自己做时更糟。有些事情并不恶心，因为那是我们。它是我们的一部分。我们的体液，我们的身体过程。另一件事是你看不到自己这样做。
Maybe if Lisa were to watch herself, you know, if someone took a video of her licking her ice cream in a weird way, she would feel disgust for that. But when it's you doing it, then, you know, you're not likely to feel that disgust. Because imagine, Chanker, how much disgust we would feel if we were, We're constantly disgusted by the things that we do. Yeah, we would be paralyzed by disgust. Yes.
也许如果丽莎看着自己，你知道，如果有人拍了她以一种奇怪的方式舔冰淇淋的视频，她会对那感到恶心。但当是你自己做时，然后，你知道，你不太可能感到那种恶心。因为想象一下，尚卡尔，如果我们是，我们不断对我们所做的事情感到恶心，我们会感到多少恶心？是的，我们会因恶心而瘫痪。是的。
When we come back, the social dimensions of disgust. What we're signaling when we express disgust to another person. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Cornell University, David Pizarro studies the science of disgust. He returns to the show today for our recurring segment, your questions answered. What we find disgusting can be shaped by where we live. It's also shaped by the moment in which we live.
当我们回来时，恶心的社会维度。当我们对另一个人表达恶心时，我们在发出什么信号。你正在收听的是隐秘大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是隐秘大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在康奈尔大学，大卫·皮扎罗研究恶心科学。他今天重返节目进行我们的常规环节，回答你的问题。我们觉得恶心的东西可以由我们居住的地方塑造。它也是由我们生活的时刻塑造的。
We received an email about that from listener Mary, who writes, People used to use the same toothpicks and pass it around the table after eating in the 1800s, or just dumping waste right into the streets back in the Middle Ages. Is our disgust ever evolving? What do you think of Mary's question, David? I think Mary makes a very good point, which is it's important to understand that social context influences all of our emotions and disgust is included in that. There are customs, there are ways of behaving that in one time and place might seem very disgusting and another one don't. Sometimes
我们收到了一封来自听众玛丽的电子邮件，她写道，在18世纪，人们在吃完饭后过去常常使用同一根牙签并在桌子上传递，或者在中世纪直接将废物倾倒到街道上。我们的恶心一直在进化吗？你觉得玛丽的问题怎么样，大卫？我认为玛丽提出了一个很好的观点，那就是重要的是要了解社会背景会影响我们所有的情绪，恶心也包含在其中。有些习俗，有些行为方式在某个时间和地点可能看起来非常恶心，而在另一个时间和地点则不然。有时
that's out of sheer necessity. We didn't always have the ability to have, you know, very clean bathrooms that we could use every day. And so as you mentioned earlier, we might burn out if we had to consistently feel disgust for just something that was a part of life. But context, social context does shape everything. And it's easy to lose sight of that when we talk about an emotion that seems so strong and to have such a strong evolutionary basis for it. We often point to the similarities and how strong some of these disgust elicitors are across cultures. But the reality is what you find disgusting and what I find disgusting is going to be some sort of result of our upbringing, our culture, our personal habits, and our individual
那是出于纯粹的必要性。我们并不总是能够拥有，你知道，我们可以每天使用的非常干净的浴室。所以正如你前面提到的，如果我们不得不一直对仅仅是生活一部分的事物感到恶心，我们可能会筋疲力尽。但背景，社会背景确实塑造了一切。当我们谈论一种看起来如此强烈并具有如此强烈的进化基础的情绪时，很容易忽视这一点。我们经常指出这些恶心诱发因素在文化中的相似性和强度有多大。但现实是，你觉得恶心和我觉得恶心将是我们成长经历、文化、个人习惯和个人对恶心事物的敏感度的某种结果。
sensitivity to disgusting things. Is it possible, David, that you think we're living in a particularly disgust, sensitive time right now? I suspect that we are. I don't have any direct data on whether or not people have been getting more disgust sensitive, and I'm certain this would vary across the world. In the United States, in this time and place, it's very easy to go around not feeling disgusted because there are so many efforts made for cleanliness. There are billions and billions of dollars spent on cleaning products. We do not want to see disgusting things in our homes. We get rid of them easily. I think it's easier than ever to live an antiseptic life. We talked in our earlier
大卫，你认为我们现在生活在一个对恶心特别敏感的时代吗？我怀疑我们是。我没有任何直接数据表明人们是否变得越来越对恶心敏感，我确信这在世界各地会有所不同。在美国，在这个时间和地点，走动而不感到恶心是非常容易的，因为人们为清洁付出了如此多的努力。在清洁产品上花费了数十亿数十亿美元。我们不想在我们的家中看到恶心的东西。我们很容易摆脱它们。我认为过上无菌的生活比以往任何时候都容易。我们在早期的
discussion about how disgust has often been used to tarnish women in public life and in politics. Remind me of some of that history, David? The rhetoric of disgust is one of those very ugly pieces of human history, but it's strong. And so what you see very clearly is that certain groups are often tagged with the emotion of disgust, usually by pointing out something about them that is perceived to be disgusting or people are trying to persuade others that they're disgusting. And so you get comments about Hillary going to the bathroom or menstruating. That's always been, something that in the hands of men is low-hanging fruit to try to to make women seem inferior in fact if you look at some of the earliest codes that we have from old
讨论中谈到了恶心如何经常被用来玷污公众生活和政治中的女性。提醒我一些那段历史，大卫？恶心的修辞是人类历史中非常丑陋的部分之一，但它很强大。所以你很清楚地看到，某些群体经常被打上恶心的情绪的标签，通常是通过指出关于他们被认为令人恶心的事情，或者人们试图说服其他人他们很恶心。所以你得到了关于希拉里去卫生间或月经的评论。这一直是一回事，在男人的手中，这是低垂的果实，试图让女性显得低人一等，事实上，如果你看一下我们从古代拥有的最早的代码
civilizations a menstruating woman is a woman who had to be separated from the camp and so in particular women's dirt women's bodily fluid that The disgusting aspects of one gender have been used against them in a very powerful way. Listener, Alon had a very interesting question about the relationship between disgust and gender stereotypes. Once when I was a boy, I saw a group of other boys playing with a snail. They dared me to touch it, but I refused because I was grossed out. So they jeered me with statements like, what, are you a girl? Even as an adult, I notice people connecting the concept of masculinity with the bravery to withstand disgust,
文明中，月经期的女性是一个必须与营地隔离的女性，所以特别是女性的污垢，女性的体液，一个性别的恶心方面已被以一种非常有力的方式用来反对她们。听众阿隆有一个关于恶心和性别刻板印象之间关系的非常有趣的问题。有一次当我还是个男孩时，我看到一群其他男孩在玩一只蜗牛。他们挑逗我去摸它，但我拒绝了，因为我觉得恶心。所以他们用这样的话嘲笑我，什么，你是个女孩吗？即使作为一个成年人，我注意到人们将男子气概的概念与抵御恶心的勇敢联系在一起，
like eating raw meat or mud wrestling, or even the movie cliche of a man on a date, placing his coat on a puddle so his girlfriend can cross without getting dirty. On the other hand, masculinity is politically associated with conservatism, which itself is associated with strong of value. version to disgusting things. How would you explain this paradox? I love this question, David. What do you think? Well, that is a really good question for Milan. I definitely agree about the masculinity. I don't know if this is a cultural universal, but it certainly is part of my experience. There was constant testing of the boundaries of how much you could deal with disgusting things. And it wasn't just
就像吃生肉或泥潭摔跤，甚至像电影里的老桥段：约会中的男士把外套铺在水坑上，好让女友过去时鞋不沾湿。另一方面，男权主义在政治上与保守主义联系在一起，而保守主义本身又与强烈的价值观、对恶心事物的厌恶相关联。你如何解释这个悖论？我喜欢这个问题，大卫。你怎么看？嗯，这对米兰来说是个非常好的问题。我绝对同意关于男子气概的看法。我不知道这是否是全人类共通的，但它确实是我经历过的一部分。人们一直在不断试探你能应对多少恶心事物的底线。而且这不仅仅是
discussed, at least in my experience. It was any sort of negative emotion as a man you were supposed to be able to deal with it. So I remember tests of pain. You know, you brought your friend in and you did something to them, see how long they could last before they complained. And if it was too fast, then they were, you know, wusses or whatever gendered insults you could bring. So I very much think that that is the case. I also think that ironically, women in their life end up having to deal with a lot more disgusting things than men ever do. So this is, I believe, largely performance on the part of men.
讨论，至少以我的经验来看是这样的。作为男人，任何负面情绪你都应该能够应付。所以我记得有关于痛苦的测试。你知道，你把朋友叫来，对他做点什么，看他能撑多久才抱怨。如果撑得太快，那你就是个懦夫，或者可以用任何性别歧视的侮辱来形容你。所以我非常认为情况就是这样。我也认为，具有讽刺意味的是，生活中的女性最终要面对的恶心事情比男人们经历的要多得多。所以，我认为这在很大程度上是男性的某种表演。
As for the conservative liberal finding, I don't know what to make of this, because this is not a gendered finding either. This is both men and women who report being more politically conservative, report being more disgust-sensitive. So, you know, there are always multiple factors that are going to influence how much disgust any given person feels. And
至于保守派和自由派的调查结果，我不知道该怎么看待，因为这也不是一个基于性别的发现。无论是自称政治上更保守的男性还是女性，都报告说自己对厌恶更敏感。所以，你知道，总有多种因素会影响任何人所感受到的厌恶程度，而且
there's going to be something like the culture, the individual difference, the male-female stereotypes, and many other things. We received an email from listener Martin, who's interested in knowing more about the intersection between disgust and religious practices. Martin writes, there was no mention at all of such concepts as original sin and its cleansing through baptism, Holy Communion, and other rights. Nor was any mention made of dietary laws and unclean foods, animals, or objects in Judaism and Islam. Are these concepts based on disgust? So, David, I know that you're not a scholar of religion, but what do you make of the role that disgust may play in
总会有一些因素，比如文化、个体差异、男女刻板印象等等。我们收到了听众马丁的电子邮件，他对了解厌恶与宗教实践之间的交集很感兴趣。马丁写道：完全没有提及原罪及其通过洗礼、圣餐和其他仪式净化的概念，也没有提及犹太教和伊斯兰教中的饮食禁忌、不洁食物、动物或物品。这些概念是基于厌恶吗？所以，大卫，我知道你不是宗教学者，但你认为厌恶在
religious practices and beliefs? Well, I love this question, Martin, because I have been increasingly interested in this aspect of not just discussed, but I would say purity more broadly. In fact, I'm teaching a seminar on this topic, and we've read a lot of literature from religious scholars and clinical psychologists. And there does seem to be this overlap in religious practices in some religions and cleanliness and purity. Sometimes it's metaphorical, like cleansing your soul through confession. Sometimes it's absolutely physical. You must do ablutions before prayer. And I think that it runs deep in our religions. I think that there is a power to purity and to being pure that has sort of metaphorically become associated with being a good person, being closer to God.
宗教实践和信仰中可能扮演什么角色？嗯，我非常喜欢这个问题，马丁，因为我越来越对这方面的议题感兴趣，这不仅仅关乎厌恶，我可以说更广泛地关乎纯洁。事实上，我正在教一门关于这个主题的研讨会，我们读了很多来自宗教学者和临床心理学家的文献。在某些宗教的宗教实践中，确实存在这种与清洁和纯洁的重叠。有时它是隐喻性的，比如通过忏悔洗涤你的灵魂。有时它是绝对物质的。你必须在祈祷前进行沐浴净手。我认为这深深植根于我们的宗教之中。我认为纯洁以及保持纯洁的力量，已经在隐喻上与成为一个好人、更接近上帝联系在了一起。
And so absolutely there is a link. And I think purity is deeper than disgust. So one of the questions Martin asks is, are these rituals driven by disgust? And they don't need to be. You don't need to be disgusted to wash your feet, you know, or do ablutions or get baptized. But I believe that it is the same underlying mechanism that we all share, which is keeping clean helps keep us disease. free. When we come back, listeners share their techniques for quieting disgust. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. By its very nature, disgust seems like one of the
所以绝对存在着某种联系。而且我认为纯洁比厌恶更深层。因此马丁提出的问题之一是，这些仪式是由厌恶驱动的吗？它们其实不必如此。你知道，洗脚、做沐浴或接受洗礼并不需要你感到厌恶。但我相信，这是我们所有人共享的同一种底层机制，那就是保持清洁有助于让我们免受疾病侵害。稍后，听众将分享他们平息厌恶的方法。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。就其本质而言，厌恶似乎是
hardest emotions to control. Our response to things that gross us out can be visceral. But as we've discussed, what we find disgusting can vary from person to person and also across time and culture. If we want to confront our own feelings of disgust, where should we start? Today, we're hearing listener suggestions and talking with psychologist David Pizarro at Cornell University. He studies the science of disgust. David, I'd like to start this conversation with a message we received from a listener named John. He's a minister in North Carolina, and he had an interesting perspective on disgust. As a young pastor, part of my clinical training was to work as a chaplain at Allentown State
最难控制的情绪之一。我们对那些让我们感到恶心的事物的反应可能是本能的。但正如我们所讨论的，我们觉得恶心的东西会因人而异，也会随时间和文化而变化。如果我们想正视自己对厌恶的感觉，应该从哪里开始呢？今天，我们将倾听听众的建议，并与康奈尔大学的心理学家大卫·皮萨罗进行交流。他专门研究厌恶的科学。大卫，我想以一位名叫约翰的听众发来的信息作为我们对话的开始。他是北卡罗来纳州的一名牧师，对厌恶有着有趣的看法。作为一名年轻的牧师，我临床培训的一部分是在 Allentown State
mental hospital in Allentown, Pennsylvania. Many of the situations I had to deal with in that setting evoked horror, revulsion, or disgust. I had to learn to face those feelings and get them under control, otherwise they would dominate the interaction, and I would have been powerless to help the patient. It's always seemed to me that there are three ways of dealing with strong, primitive emotions. One is to conceal them, to simply hide our feelings from others without dealing with them at all. This leaves the emotions driving the bust, we're just hiding it, and we're not being honest about it with ourselves. The other is to control, sort of like the Vonklins in Star Trek, to manhandle the emotions and try not to let them direct our actions.
担任院牧，这是宾夕法尼亚州阿伦敦的一家精神病院。我在那个环境中不得不应对的许多情况都唤起了恐惧、反感或厌恶。我必须学会直面这些感受并加以控制，否则它们将主导互动，我也将无力帮助患者。在我看来，处理强烈、原始的情绪总是有三种方法。一种是将它们掩盖起来，只是向他人隐藏我们的感觉，而根本不处理它们。这让情绪在暗中驱动一切，我们只是把它藏起来，而且我们对自己并不诚实。另一种是控制，有点像《星际迷航》中的瓦肯人，强行压制情绪，尽量不让它们指导我们的行动。
But the best is to confront, to honestly face the primitive emotions, acknowledge them to ourselves and sometimes to others, but also to understand them and set them aside, realizing that they do not represent reality, but simply an unhelpful emotional response. David, I hadn't thought of this before, but if you're a pastor or a counselor who is trying to help others, you have to be able to listen to things that people do with compassion and not turn away and disgust. That's absolutely right. And I think John is making such an important point. about how we deal with other humans that might be disgusting to us.
但最好的办法是直面，诚实地面对原始情绪，向我们自己、有时也向他人承认它们，同时理解它们并将它们放在一边，意识到它们并不代表现实，而只是一种无益的情绪反应。大卫，我以前没想过这一点，但如果你是一位牧师或咨询师，试图帮助他人，你必须能够带着同情心倾听人们所做的事情，而不是转身离去并感到厌恶。完全正确。我认为约翰提出了一个非常重要的观点，即我们如何对待那些对我们来说可能很恶心的人类。
And it sounds like John is taking a very compassionate approach. I do not think that it is always the case that these emotions are not in touch with reality. I think we've made the case that disgust is important. It's functional. And sometimes it gives you a signal that you should avoid something. But we have other goals. and if one of your goals is to show compassion and mercy to somebody, some of the people who are worst off in society,
听起来约翰采取了一种非常富有同情心的方法。我不认为这些情绪总是与现实脱节。我认为我们已经证明了厌恶是重要的。它是具有功能性的。有时它会给你一个信号，告诉你应该避开某些东西。但我们有其他的目标，如果你的目标之一是对某人表现出同情和怜悯，也就是社会上处境最糟糕的一些人，
people who might not have the ability to bathe regularly or who might be carrying disease, it is one of the ultimate signs of, I think, compassion to be able to go about your business without letting that bother you. Because from the perspective of the person, they know that others are disgusted by them. And just to feel that somebody isn't showing disgust toward them,
那些可能没有能力经常洗澡或可能携带疾病的人，能够心平气和地做你自己的事而不受其干扰，我认为这是同情心的终极表现之一。因为从那个人的角度来看，他们知道其他人对他们感到厌恶。而仅仅感觉到有人没有对他们表现出厌恶，
I think is an act of true kindness. And there are many stories of religious figures, including Mother Teresa, who would purposefully make a show of handling, touching, hugging, kissing people who would otherwise be viewed as so disgusting by others as a way to show that compassion can override that disgust. I'm wondering if we're doing work that is mission-driven or something we are deeply passionate about.
我认为这就是一种真正的善良行为。有许多关于宗教人物的故事，包括特蕾莎修女，他们会刻意去接触、触摸、拥抱、亲吻那些在其他人看来非常恶心的人，以此来证明同情心可以压倒这种厌恶。我在想，如果我们从事的事业是由使命驱动的，或者是我们深感热衷的事情，
Are we less likely to experience disgust? I mean, we heard from a number of doctors and nurses, for example, who feel that they have a much higher threshold for dealing with disease and injuries that others might find disgusting. Yes, I think that there are two things going on there. One is that people who might not be as easily disgusted go into those kinds of jobs. But that's not the whole story. There is research showing that first year of medical school, pre and posts,
我们经历厌恶的可能性会更小吗？我的意思是，我们听取了许多医生和护士的意见，例如，他们觉得自己对付别人可能会觉得恶心的疾病和伤害的门槛要高得多。是的，我认为那里有两件的事情在起作用。一个是那些不容易感到厌恶的人会选择从事这类工作。但这并不是全部。有研究表明，医学院的第一年，前后对比，
or right when you get into medical school, your disgust sensitivity levels are pretty much the same as everybody else's. But after that year of having to do things like dissect cadavers, you adapt, and you adapt specifically to human bodies and the kinds of things that you need to, you know, deal with as a medical doctor or other medical professional every day. But I do think that you're pointing Shankar to something deeper that intersects with John's question, which is we talked about love and lust overriding, disgust, and it's easy when it's your child, you know, to be less grossed out by their diaper. it's easy when it's somebody that you're sexually attracted to.
或者刚进入医学院时，你的厌恶敏感度水平和所有人差不多。但在经历了一年诸如解剖尸体之类的事情之后，你适应了，并且专门针对人体以及作为医生或其他医疗专业人员每天需要应对的各种事情进行了适应。但我确实认为，香卡，你指出了更深层次的东西，它与约翰的问题相交织，也就是我们谈到了爱和色欲可以压倒厌恶，当那是你的孩子时，你很容易不对他们的尿布感到那么恶心，当那是你对其产生性吸引的人时，这也很容易。
But when it's somebody who is the worst of the worst in society, can you allow compassion to override the reflexive disgust that others feel? And I think this is just the part of discipline that might come from dedicating your life to that sort of thing. We've talked on Hidden Brain in the past about the concept of awe and the many benefits it can have for our mental health and outlook, listener Catherine wrote to talk about how she uses beauty to help her grapple with things that she finds disgusting. I've struggled with disgust sensitivity all of my life
但当那是社会中最糟糕的人时，你能让同情心压倒其他人感到的反射性厌恶吗？我认为这只是将生命奉献给这类事情所带来的纪律的一部分。我们过去在《隐藏的大脑》中讨论过敬畏的概念及其对我们的心理健康和前景可以带来的许多益处，听众凯瑟琳写信谈到她如何利用美来帮助自己应对她感到恶心的事情。我一生都在与厌恶敏感度作斗争，
and believe it played an important role in a serious eating disorder I developed when I was 12.5. In addition to using medication and therapy and other medical treatments, I've learned to use beauty and awe as a, a way to manage my disgust. When I feel disgusted and I'm triggered, I think back on something I found beautiful, a flower, a waterfall. I'm curious if there's any evidence for this approach. And if you have recommendations on other sort of daily habits or mindsets, those of us who
并且相信它在我12岁半时发展出的严重饮食失调中发挥了重要作用。除了使用药物、疗法和其他医疗手段外，我学会了利用美和敬畏作为管理厌恶的一种方法。当我感到厌恶并被触动时，我会回想起我发现美好的事物，比如一朵花、一个瀑布。我很好奇这种方法是否有任何证据支持。如果你对其他日常习惯或心态有什么建议，能让我们这些
struggle can use, so disgust affects us less and our reactions don't hurt the people around us. What do you think of Catherine's strategy and do you have any suggestions, David? I think it's a wonderful strategy, and it's quite inspiring, actually, to hear Catherine describe it that way. And I believe that those kinds of strategies are available to us all. She asked for some specifics. There is a strategy of what's called attentional deployment, so just simply shifting your attention from one thing to another so that you're not paying attention to the thing that you find. disgusting. I think more
饱受困扰的人使用，从而让厌恶对我们的影响减少，我们的反应也不会伤害周围的人。你如何看待凯瑟琳的策略，你有什么建议吗，大卫？我认为这是一个绝妙的策略，而且听到凯瑟琳这样描述，实际上相当鼓舞人心。我相信这类策略是我们所有人都可以使用的。她询问了一些具体细节。有一种策略叫做注意力部署，也就是简单地将你的注意力从一件事转移到另一件事上，这样你就不会去关注你觉得恶心的东西。我认为更
effective is reappraisal. So appraising something as different. Not thinking about it as the disgusting thing, but rather maybe as having beauty in it, focusing on that. You know, the low level form of this is when you're a kid and you're watching a gross
有效的是重新评价。也就是把某物评价为不同的东西。不要把它想成那个恶心的东西，而是把它想象成具有美感的东西，专注于这一点。你知道，这种做法的低级形式是，当你还是个孩子的时候，你在看一部恶心的
movie convince yourself that it's ketchup and not blood, you're sort of reappraising at a low level so that you don't feel disgusted. That's a bit harder when you know the reality of the situation. In fact, interestingly, it's harder for odors than it is for vision. It's hard. But we have a lot of these kinds of strategies for emotion regulation that are available to us. And I think that is part of being a mature adult who's able to effectively
电影，说服自己那是番茄酱而不是血，你在某种程度上进行低水平的重新评价，这样你就不会感到厌恶。当你了解情况的真相时，这就有点难了。事实上，有趣的是，对气味来说比对视觉来说更难。这很难。但我们有很多这样可用于情绪调节的策略。我认为这是一名成熟成年人的部分表现，能够有效地
regulate these emotions in order to be more effective at dealing with other human beings. And in this case, showing kindness and compassion to other human beings. Whatever, whatever works for you, I think, is the good thing to aim for. I mean, I'm thinking about someone who's a nurse or someone who's a doctor and maybe, you know, you're interacting with the patient and perhaps your immediate visceral response might be discussed. But if you spend a little time, you might say, you know, this person has an interesting history, this person has an interesting story, this person has interesting ideas. And in some ways, what you're reminding you, yourself off is that the thing that has brought the person into the hospital might not be
调节这些情绪，以便更有效地与其他人打交道。在这种情况下，就是对其他人表现出善良和同情。无论什么方法对你管用，我认为都是很好的目标。我的意思是，我在想某个护士或某个医生，也许，你知道，你正在与患者互动，也许你直接的本能反应可能是厌恶。但如果你花一点时间，你可能会说，你知道，这个人有一段有趣的经历，这个人有一个有趣的故事，这个人有有趣的观点。在某些情况下，你在提醒自己的是，把这个人带进医院的事情可能不是
the entire sum of who that person is. That's a lovely way of saying it. And I think that we often talk about objectification of other humans when talking about sexuality. But there is a way in which we can objectify somebody's physical body in this negative way. And I think what you're pointing to is that, you know, these are people with hopes and desires and wishes and dreams. And they are as interesting as anybody else. And opening yourself up to that will be a natural way of shifting your attention, of reappraising the situation. And you know what? We get used to smells. We get used to the site of disease. All of that we can get accustomed to. But what you can't do is take back the disgust that you demonstrated to somebody who was just there because they need
这个人的全部。这是一个很好的表达方式。我认为我们在谈论性时经常谈到对其他人类的物化。但在某种程度上，我们可以用这种负面的方式将某个人的物理身体物化。我认为你所指的是，你知道，这些人是有希望、有欲望、有愿望和梦想的人。他们和其他人一样有趣。向这一点敞开心扉将是转移注意力、重新评价情况的自然方式。你知道吗？我们习惯了气味。我们习惯了疾病的景象。所有这些我们都可以适应。但你无法收回的是你向一个只是因为需要
your help. It can sometimes be an alienating experience when you're disgusted by something that most people like. Listener, Allison, has an interesting hack for getting people to understand where she's coming from when she tells them that she dislikes cheese. A lot of people don't quite understand the extent to which it disgusts me. So a few years back, I started saying, well, just substitute the words dog waste for cheese, as in you don't even like dog waste on your pizza? What about just a little bit of dog waste
你的帮助而来到这里的人所表现出的厌恶。当你对大多数人喜欢的东西感到厌恶时，这有时会成为一种疏离的体验。听众艾莉森有一个有趣的妙招，可以让人们理解她不喜欢奶酪时的想法。很多人并不太理解它让我感到恶心的程度。所以几年前，我开始说，好吧，只要把奶酪这个词换成狗屎就行了，比如你甚至不喜欢披萨上有狗屎？哪怕只有一点点狗屎
cooked in the sauce? Or if I just throw some dog waste into the salad, are you okay picking it out? That dip has dog waste in it, but it's mild. You can barely taste it. They get it now, even if they think I'm a freak. What are you making of Allison's strategy, David? I love it. I love it. Now, of course, I'm sure that she can't convince people that cheese is disgusting, but at the very least she can convince them, once you find something disgusting, what is a reasonable way to eat it? And in her case, there is no reasonable way to eat it. I think that is a very, very smart way to fight that fight.
在酱汁里煮过呢？或者如果我在沙拉里扔一些狗屎，你介意把它挑出来吗？那个蘸酱里有狗屎，但很温和。你几乎尝不出来。他们现在明白了，即使他们认为我是个怪胎。你如何看待艾莉森的策略，大卫？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。当然，我确信她无法让人们相信奶酪是恶心的，但至少她能让他们明白，一旦你觉得某样东西恶心，怎么吃才算合理？在她的例子里，怎么吃都不合理。我认为这是对抗这种状况的一个非常非常聪明的办法。
In our earlier conversation, David, we talked about how disgust is used in politics to vilify opponents, but it's also used in public health to try and trigger people's disgust about certain behaviors. Listener Garima writes, I wanted to share an example of how Singapore's health minister used disgust for his anti-vaping campaign. The short-form video went mega-viral. It speaks the language of Gen Z and channels a very strong emotion to highlight the impact of vaping. Time to spill some tea. This is a healthy lung. And this one is unhealthy. white stuff is infected past. And when you vape, it may smell like watermelon or liegee,
在我们之前的对话中，大卫，我们讨论了厌恶如何在政治中被用来丑化对手，但它也被用于公共卫生中，试图触发人们对某些行为的厌恶。听众加里马写道：我想分享一个例子，关于新加坡卫生部长如何在他的反电子烟活动中利用厌恶情绪。这段短视频病毒式传播了。它说着Z世代的语言，并引导出一种非常强烈的情绪来强调电子烟的影响。是时候爆点猛料了。这是一个健康的肺。而这个是不健康的。白色的东西是感染的脓液。当你吸电子烟时，它可能闻起来像西瓜或荔枝，
but actually you are taking in very harmful chemical substances. What do you make of using disgust in public health campaigns, David? I think they can be very effective. You and I are probably of a generation that remember pictures of diseased lungs being used to scare us out of smoking. It can be tricky because there are, is sometimes a such a strong disgust that is induced that might even be wrapped up with fear and what you might get is people simply avoiding the message. And what you don't want to do
但实际上你吸入了非常有害的化学物质。大卫，你怎么看在公共卫生运动中使用厌恶？我认为它们非常有效。你和我可能属于这样一代人：还记得用来吓唬我们戒烟的病肺图片。这可能很棘手，因为有时诱发的厌恶感太强烈了，甚至可能与恐惧交织在一起，你可能会得到的结果是人们干脆选择回避这个信息。而你最不想做的
is let people disengage from the message. But I think there is a sweet spot there and I think that it's been used quite effectively in hand-washing campaigns for when their pandemics like the flu. I think it's an emotion that can be harnessed for good in this way. You know, I remember an anti-smoking public health campaign some years ago that used the tagline, kissing a smoker is like licking an ashtray. And it reminded me that even though the public health core message, you know, smoking is bad for you, it can give you lung cancer, it can give you emphysema, you would think that those messages would be what people listen to. It's Striking that, at least for many young people, the idea that, you know, kissing a smoker is like licking an ashtray, that message might end up being more persuasive.
就是让人们脱离这个信息。但我认为这里有一个最佳平衡点，而且我认为它在流感等大流行期间的洗手运动中被非常有效地利用了。我认为这是一种可以以这种方式被利用来行善的情绪。你知道，我记得几年前有一个反吸烟的公共卫生运动，用了一句标语：“亲吻吸烟者就像舔烟灰缸”。这提醒了我，尽管公共卫生核心信息（你知道，吸烟对你有害，它会给你带来肺气肿）你会认为这些信息才是人们会听取的。令人震惊的是，至少对许多年轻人来说，“亲吻吸烟者就像舔烟灰缸”这个想法，这个信息最终可能会更具说服力。
Yeah, I think that's right. And that does, I think, hit a sweet spot where the disgust is working, but it's not kicking in the fear that would maybe lead to avoidance. So as a strategy, and in particular, one that is getting at the fears of young people, which is that I might not be attractive to the people I find it. I think that could be a strong one. I don't know if anybody ever did this, but one of the things that kept me from smoking was the knowledge that it would give me wrinkles. And I just didn't, I was so vain that I did not want to have wrinkles early on in life. I mean, it's so funny and striking to me that people care more about their appearance and their vanity than about their, you know, their capacity to breathe.
是的，我认为这很对。而且我认为这确实击中了一个最佳平衡点，这里的厌恶起作用了，但它没有引发可能导致回避的恐惧。因此作为一种策略，特别是那种能够触及年轻人恐惧的策略——也就是我可能对那些让我心动的人没有吸引力。我认为这可能是一个强有力的策略。我不知道是否有人这样做过，但让我戒烟的事情之一是知道它会给我带来皱纹。我太虚荣了，不希望在生命早期就有皱纹。我的意思是，对我来说，人们更关心自己的外表和虚荣心，而不是他们的呼吸能力，这真是太有趣也太惊人了。
I know, and to die. I think it's very hard for us to represent. and something as a mortal risk, but it's easy to think that we might be ugly today. David Pizarro is a psychologist at Cornell University. David, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. This was great. Thank you listeners for sending in such wonderful, vivid stories.
我知道，还有死亡。我认为我们很难将某事表现为致命风险，但我们很容易认为我们今天可能会变丑。大卫·皮萨罗是康奈尔大学的心理学家。大卫，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。这太棒了。谢谢听众们发来如此精彩、生动的故事。
We also heard today from psychologist Alison Ledgerwood, who studies the negativity bias at the University of California, David. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love Hidden Brain and want more of the ideas we explore on the show, check out our new YouTube channel. And if you like our videos, please share them with a friend or family member. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们今天还听取了加州大学戴维斯分校研究消极偏差的心理学家艾莉森·莱德伍德的意见。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》并想了解我们在节目中探讨的更多想法，请查看我们的新YouTube频道。如果你喜欢我们的视频，请与朋友或家人分享。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。